project Veritas has just released a
massive story
for Pfizer director I want to make sure
I get his title actually uh correct
Pfizer director of research and
development strategic operations mRNA
scientific Planner on camera saying that
they're exploring mutating kovid for
profit hey if they want to sell vaccines
why don't they mutate the virus
themselves by putting in monkeys and
spreading it around so that they can
then make vaccines preemptively sell
them because I'm going to say a bunch of
other things this director is actually
saying on camera that he believes kovid
came from the Wuhan lab because they
were doing let's just call it mutating
the virus
and then it may have gotten out and he
says it's one of the things they fear
but hey don't tell anyone he says it's
actually pretty crazy because the story
was crazy the story is crazier than this
my understanding of the story is that
when James O'Keefe and his crew
confronted this man after they had
recorded him this man became violent so
I'm told and had to be restrained after
attacking the cameraman now I don't know
the full details about what happened but
this is actually a pretty crazy story so
we got to talk about that and then of
course we got tons of political stuff
Kevin McCarthy finally announced he's
kicking off Schiff and swalwell from the
intelligence committee they're pissed
off about this because it's huge because
these are these are guys these are not
good guys swallow of course is kicked
off due to his association with Fung
Fung the Chinese spy Now Matt Gates
pushed back on that a little bit saying
maybe it's a little too much because
that was a long time ago but Adam Schiff
he lied to the American people over and
over again about evidence that Donald
Trump was colluding with Russia that's
just not true so we'll get into that
plus we got the U.S sending a bunch of
Tanks to Ukraine joining Germany and I
believe France and so maybe it was is
right of the Doomsday Clock scientists
to crank that clock forward before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com click that join us button
become a member support our work
directly and you will get access to the
uncensored members only show we will
have up for you tonight we had a great
show last night we had a great show on
Monday with Stephen Crowder we have a
huge library of content check it out at
timcast.com as a member you're
supporting our work directly so we can
do this show but a bunch of other
cultural Endeavors like the coffee shop
skate shop game shop hangout Club thing
that we're building and we want to set
up a bunch of these all over the country
to create physical spaces where people
can hang out and just share ideas live
Etc but you'll also notice over at
timcast.com there's a new ad normally
we're just advertising Tales from the
inverted world but now you can see here
Tim cast IRL with Lou gradkowski Alex
Jones Alex Stein Blair White Michael
Mouse Austin Texas April 14th get your
tickets now at timcast.com
to the Vulcan theater there's going to
be a whole lot of fun we're going to do
the show live on stage with a stu with
with a I should say with a live audience
it's gonna be a lot of fun and of course
you can see that uh those are the guests
that we're gonna have there and we're
gonna be doing the show from Austin that
whole week I'm really excited so uh
thanks to everybody who supports us
making all this stuff possible and then
we plan on doing this you know really
I'd love to do it once a month but it's
very very difficult to do so maybe once
every quarter we might go out and do a
live show somewhere in some City on
stage and that's uh thanks to you and
all of your support as members we're
able to invest the money to to start
setting up these Live Events so go to
timcast.com become a member smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends we got
the whole hotep crew joining us tonight
we got hotep Jesus back how's it going
man hey what's up man feels good to be
back good to have you what are you doing
who are you what do you do
um well you know in my off time I knit
10 pool beanies
well you haven't sent me one
I got you next time I come back all
right I'm trying to find the perfect one
because last time I brought you being
didn't wear it I'm like okay I didn't do
the right one I didn't do the right
thing on that one I'm gonna get you
right fit we're working on it we're
working on getting beanies it's tough
are you yeah because there's so many
different kinds kinds of different
materials and we got to make sure
they're done right and most of these
private label companies don't do them so
we have to have like specific design
it's a weird process yeah you gotta do
them silk silk beanie that's gotta get
some soap beans I got I mean I'm
sorry black hair
Focus to me
but it feels good to be here man yeah
motivation yeah I'm here with Canyon
hotel uncle hotep and uh we just
released the grifties the grifties yeah
I'm excited for this well I'm sorry we
didn't release it it's coming it's
coming tomorrow youtube.com
Otep nation and this is our Premiere
award show it's the third annual and
basically we reward the grifters we
recognized them for uh the great work or
lack of
and all the Griffiths are doing yeah but
it's a fun time uh
Tim IRL you guys are a sponsoring that
we appreciate you I feel like I need a
sound button
when I said that tip pulls down you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah I thought I
thought it was a good idea we talked
about on the show yeah we were like we
gotta we gotta it's about the cultural
Endeavors it's about doing something
that can create a community that can get
people involved yeah create something
long-standing maybe in 20 years it'll be
the 20th annual or 23rd annual you know
grifties and everyone's gonna you know
there's gonna be some kid who's born
tomorrow who's going to be 23 being like
yo we're going to the Griffies we got
tickets it's going to be old hotels hey
for coming kids that's gonna be cool
right absolutely well hopefully you know
by then I didn't you know sold off my
shares and I can chill somewhere in
Texas
but yeah man that's the dream we want to
do uh we want to do one in person we
talked about that I don't think the time
was right we need you needed a lot of
time to plan something like that you do
you know it's hard that's what I was
saying like the event that we're
planning is it's expensive and difficult
to do yeah but you know it
time you know it's not really about the
money it's about the time because
there's a lot of planning and details
that you don't want to miss and you want
to make it memorable when you do your
first one yeah so yeah hopefully 2024
will have one live in person but right
now it's all digital we have an All-Star
cast on there uh Chrissy May is on there
right on spoiler
um Alex Stein
spoiler yeah so we went out and got the
best of the best Sonny Johnson uh we
went out and got the best of the best
talent every year we go out and get
great talent we had last year we had
Jason Whitlock that was cool
um but yeah you know just something fun
man Enlighten the move every time you
talk on politics it's like sometimes
it's just too too much tension yeah
right and it's just angst and it's like
no let's have fun let's let's crack
jokes and yeah right on man and you got
Canon Hotel yeah what's going on
everybody salute cannon hotep from Hotel
Nation uh political commentator social
commentator and Resident 2A expert for
Hotel Nation uh they usually consult me
when they want to know anything when it
anything regarding anything with guns or
laws things of that nature right on I
dig it we got Uncle Uncle in the back
how's it going man so there's medication
ain't kick in yet we're gonna get no
he's all right all right so let's uh
well let's go we also got Hannah Claire
brimwell she's hanging out hi I'm Hannah
brimlow I'm a writer for timcast.com
we got Phil Labonte taking it Taking the
seat for Ian what's up everybody uh I am
Phil from uh the heavy metal band All
That Remains and I have a terrible time
keeping my mouth shut Ian is uh
currently on a mission to save bocus Mr
Boca sarcat okay Mr Buck has got kidney
failure Advanced kidney failure because
his kidneys are underdeveloped and he's
got a messed up heart so he can't get a
kidney transplant but he's getting
experimental cat stem cell therapy but
because he's in such bad shape we're
finding out now that he didn't have
enough fat so they've got it's gonna
take him a long time to culture the stem
cells so it can take longer than we
thought but uh Ian might actually be
back be back early because of that but
for the time being you know fill in his
seat there you go man I'm here helping
out we got surge pressing the buttons yo
what's up everybody at search.com it's
gonna be a fun episode we got some big
news start off so let's jump into this
story right away we got this from
timcast.com Project Veritas releases
video of Pfizer exec discussing mutating
covid-19 with directed Evolution the
reason for wanting to mute the virus
Walker told an undercover journalist is
so that the company can stay ahead of
the game and continue to profit from the
vaccines quote one of the things we are
exploring is like why don't we just
mutate it ourselves so we could create
preemptively develop new vaccines right
so we have to do that if we're going to
do that though there's a risk of like as
you can imagine no one wants to be
having a Pharma company mutating effing
viruses Walker said Walker continued
from what I've heard is the Pfizer
scientists are optimizing covet mutation
process but they're going slow because
everyone is very cautious obviously they
don't want to accelerate it too much I
think they are also just trying to do it
as an exploratory worry thing because
you obviously don't want to advertise
that you are figuring out future
mutations I'm just going to pause right
there in the video with with uh this
this Pfizer this is the director of
strategic director of research and
development strategic operations he says
no no no it's not getting a function
research
you're not allowed to gain of function
research it's directed Evolution to
explore Advance you know evolving this
virus
this is crazy stuff he goes on to say
well he's got a bunch of quotes here let
me see if I can search for this and see
if they've uh put the quote here on
Wuhan he says quote you have to be very
controlled to make sure that this virus
coveted that you mutate doesn't create
something that just goes everywhere
which I suspect is the way that the
virus started in Wuhan to be honest it
makes no sense that this virus popped
out of nowhere it's bullish this is to
stress Jordan Tristan Walker Pfizer
director of research and development
strategic operations saying he believes
kovid originated in a Wuhan lab due to
directed Evolution mutation research as
he calls it the crazy thing is
I don't I I don't have the sources here
to to back all this up it's just what
I'm hearing that we're going to be
getting more information from the
Veritas team when they confronted this
guy and said we have you on camera
admitting to these things he then
physically attacked the project Veritas
crew security had to intervene and
subdue him and the police actually got
involved and asked if they wanted to
press charges Veritas said no I don't
know the full details on that and I will
just say that is alleged for now but I
can't wait to see that video I don't
think Veritas is the kind of crew or the
kind of group who's going to say
something unless they have it on camera
especially considering the smears that
are out against them so take that one
you know hold it back for a little bit
but that is crazy to hear so whenever I
I so here's what happens James does
these the undercover journalists will
will interview somebody get them to talk
about it this guy candidly says don't
tell anybody here's what we're doing
they then get the footage James O'Keefe
then confronts them he says we have you
on camera saying these things he does it
all the time we've seen it all the time
so when I'm hearing that they got
attacked
sounds believable to me um you know
I really want them to uh test this on
Turtles and then name the Turtles
Michelangelo
[Music]
I'd be mean to the turtles though man it
would be well I mean if they had a
mutagen that would make my turtles large
humanoid sentient ninjas I'd be like
okay well maybe that's not a bad thing
Turtles might enjoy that yeah yeah they
could be crime Fighters you never know
no but the crazy thing is they're doing
it on monkeys this guy talks about how
he's like basically you you give the
monkey the virus and then you isolate
the more virulent strain and then you
keep forcing it and and it's crazy and
you can direct the evolution and make it
do these things yo it sounds like gain
of function recently I was getting ready
to say it I'm like you say it's not
gained a function but then go on to
describe gain a function yeah it's
exactly what he did it's like saying my
wife going oh I don't go to Target I go
to Target
[Applause]
it's like without you did yeah when
fauci was in the hearing with Rand Paul
and Rand Paul's like I have here a
document saying you to gain a function
research in fact she's like we didn't do
gain of function research which of
course is is evolving a virus we just
alter the virus by having it change over
time and it's like okay dude you know
what man you've got such a great vouch
unit yeah I mean it's it's meant to be
like derisively over the top it sounds
safe though no what does yeah just take
the virus and you just mutated and
mutate that sounds really that's how
Ebola was started bro was it yeah it
could it couldn't it couldn't affect
humans and then it got taught to really
yeah is that I don't I've never heard
that is that true yeah as I had looked
it up that's a hotep take right there
that's not exclusive
yeah right that sounds like
non-mainstream nudge if you know what I
mean it's not mainstream now which I'll
say it like that he loyal to the foil
like you're gonna get you're gonna get
medium matters riding up crazy
conspiracy they're gonna write those I
don't know anyways yeah don't worry
about it last night
on conspiracy theorist Cannon Hotel yes
well you know they're gonna they're
gonna come outside this Veritas stuff is
fake they're gonna say this guy's just
making things up yeah that's the
craziest thing I mean maybe but like
let's entertain that like why would this
guy
sitting down to dinner with some dude
I'm presumably on a date why would he
come out and be like hey here's all the
dirty stuff we're doing yeah maybe I
guess he felt like he was impressing the
person that he's he's out all of the
body language is him like sitting
forward and being like Oh my gosh so fun
on the date that could be white because
he felt like he betrayed him if they
were on a date and it's like and he
comes up he's he it could be I don't
know I don't know man like she loved me
I'm like no no it could be I think if
they assuming that the tax story is is
correct I'm waiting for the confirmation
it's because this guy basically is
admitting to like Global level
international incident
malfeasance but we we you know well we
can't find his LinkedIn page already so
I don't know I did a lot of work trying
to find it right but like it's not
obvious he's obviously clearly proud of
like what position he's in he's willing
to talk about it pretty openly like I'm
surprised that it's not more obvious who
this person is unless Pfizer who's going
to oh we terminated that person several
weeks ago he was talking so a matter of
factly about it like he it was just it
was just rolling off the tongue we uh we
wrote this sketch for James we we
haven't we haven't done and I don't know
if we ever will so I'll just tell people
what the sketch was that we wrote for
project Veritas and it's that one of the
employees at timcast keeps seeing in the
corner of his eye like James O'Keefe
like filming him from a distance and
like lurking around he's getting all
paranoid like James O'Keefe is filming
me man and we're like dude James O'Keefe
is not filming you and then like one day
he sees James like in the woods just
like staring at him and it runs off and
then finally at the end of of the bit
he's like guys I'm really sorry I got so
paranoid and thought James O'Keefe was
filming me obviously he's not out to get
me and we're like thank you oh and then
we're like so what are you doing tonight
and he goes oh I got a date and then
James O'Keefe walks up in a wig and then
and then the guy goes come here baby let
me tell you about some corporate
malfeasance I'm involved in but like the
point of the joke is all of these people
like basically what what Veritas has
been very successful at is they go on
Tinder dates they go on Tinder in a
certain area and they see you like they
keep swiping until they find Pfizer
executive or whatever but then these
guys are on dates with these young women
and they're like let me tell you about
the illegal things I'm doing it's just
are they impressing women by saying this
like I kind of Claire would you be
impressed if a guy come to you and said
let me tell you about all the illegal
things I'm involved in
um I think people would I wouldn't
personally be impressed but I think
people will say stuff like that to be
like look I'm not just like someone who
works in the office like I have in
information I have decision making power
like it's a posturing right it's like I
think I would keep them talking I think
I would want to know what they're doing
but like it's not that I would be like
well let's have a second date yeah
that's a bad look that's a bad look you
know I couldn't imagine any woman being
attracted to the man after he just
snitched on the company
it reminds me of like guys who are like
I have this kind of car like whatever
else like unless she's also interested
demonstrating value well there's no
loyalty there right so like this is the
first impression you're on a date with
the girl and it's like I don't even have
loyalty to people that cut my checks I'm
gonna tell you their deepest darkest
dirt so if I'm a chick I'm like well
what are you gonna do with the
information I tell you right like it's
got to drive the Yoni up but also look
at the guys and the women that they take
out that tell this stuff they don't look
like they had much of a social life
that's true yeah and then you get
somebody that looks like a eight or a
ten you don't really got much exciting
have you guys seen that Meme where it's
like the the access axis of like women
and it's it's the hot hot um
so somebody took it because all the
crazy zero but super hot was it said
unicorn someone took that and changed
unicorn to James O'Keefe like guys if
you are a frumpy dude of moderate means
and the hottest chick in the world is
asking you about corporate malfeasance
at your company is James O'Keefe come on
is this what it is you're being set up
in some sort of fashion yeah I mean if
you're like rich or something or you're
like a tall model guy is all chiseled
you understand like you know why this
chick's into you but yeah these these
guys they fall for it every single time
well and they like talking about it
that's my point like if there's a girl
and maybe you're like a little so
shocker you don't know what to talk
about on the state and she keeps being
like so tell me more about your job oh
my gosh you can do that you can release
the mrnas some kind of Spidey session
I'll tell you whatever you want yeah but
to be Fair like when someone is on a
date when you're talking about yourself
like that you're trying to put on the
best be as impressive as you can be and
you don't obviously they don't want to
seem over the top but they also want to
seem interesting enough to have earned a
second date and if you're you know if
you are like kind of a homebody or a
dude that's like you know kind of a nerd
dude or whatever or a bookish kind of
person you're out on a date you get that
this is your chance to go ahead and show
off and stunt and actually be in a
position where you know what you're
talking about you're gonna grab that and
you're gonna be like let me ride this
all the way into six town you know
especially if she keeps asking you
that's the one thing this girl wants to
talk about this is the number one
mistake men make on dates with women
they talk about themselves what do we
know about women women love talking
about themselves if you let a woman talk
about herself all night at the end of
the night she's gonna be like oh you're
a really nice guy I'm like no I just let
you talk I just wanted to talk you have
no idea you didn't ask me any questions
she'll never ask you any questions it'll
be at the end of the day oh okay so tell
me about you it's like yeah two hours
for dinner and whatnot right you just
like check please but then they called
their friends and like he's such a good
listener it's so nice and that's that's
what you want to go for that just
happens to be my strength I'm a really
really good listener so you know that's
what girls would say oh you're such a
really good listen like yeah that is you
know but I think guys can learn from
that like you don't have to go on a date
if she's on a date with you she has some
level of respect You've Won some some
you know level of uh trust I guess you
can say unless you look like Chris
Farley and she looks like Cyndi Lauper
Yeah
James you've been set up by somebody
somebody's definitely set up because to
your point uh like if she's constantly
asking you about your job and you know
your job is some kind of like you got
some clearance or something like that
yeah you should be really wary about why
she keeps asking about especially
considering the topic too like I mean if
you're in that business or if you're
around that kind of stuff and like it's
like presumably you're not like taking
her to your office on like a second date
right like theoretically there'd be some
other conversation like so do you like
movies like it's the only thing you want
to talk about is the Pfizer vaccine I
mean but here's the thing we gotta know
the batting average I want to see the
girls he sends out and see what is their
batting average like is it one out of
ten guys that fall for it I imagine he
sends out our top secret like that is
like yeah but what is the batting
average right like right success rate
with getting somebody to snitch I doubt
he's sending out tens you know like
model looking women with thousands of
fun they're probably like moderately
attractive women so these guys are
excited but but then you make a good
point how many times has James O'Keefe
sent out a crew yeah and they come back
with nothing nothing yeah that's what I
want to know I bet a lot yeah it might
be a numbers game right like oh one of
these dupes there's 10 guys working
fires or one of these dupes gonna there
was a one of the Twitter guys we talked
about this I felt bad because he like
he was complaining about I think it was
on Twitter guys complaining about
malfeasance at Twitter saying that they
do these things they're bad I don't like
it blah blah yeah and so he wasn't
really a bad guy he should call it out
but then it's like imagine you're this
dude and you're on a date and this
girl's opening up to you she's asking
you about your interests she's kind of
attractive you're like man this is this
is I feel I feel cared about is so great
and then like a day later she's like bro
I'm just secretly recording you to
expose your company I have no interest
any time that's like that's like the
scene from Indiana Jones where he does
the kaliman rips the heart out and
you're like oh I feel bad for these guys
that's got to be devastating because my
red flag in this video the minute he
said gain a function I'd have been like
yeah how do you know what that means how
do you know them where did it come from
you know what I mean yeah Alex Jones
right yeah and and you'd think like
these these guys would be on guard and
the first thing they do at a dinner date
or whatever is like so do you listen to
Alex Jones be like yeah all right later
like you're James O'Keefe where is he no
but I'm telling you it's like so they
can seem cool right like they're
bragging about the job and all this
information they have and you seem
interested so it's like oh I can tell
you this kind of Insider thing like
that's not like totally implausible in
dating right everyone like you said like
wants to seem like them their best
selves on a first date but like if you
suddenly feel like you're wielding power
and this person is impressed with it
like you're more likely to try and show
off and in this case like because
they're not good they're not gonna be
able to date like hey look look
I'm a level 10 wizard in my Dungeons and
Dragons
if you play your cards right I'll let
you come to the game no no no no no this
is what I want to see James project
Veritas I know you guys have a lot of
donors who give you money on ideological
grounds like expose the bad guys but you
know there's the Veritas b-sides where
it's like sitting down within it with a
with a big Pharma executive works for
like you know Eli Lilly and the chick's
like so like what do you get what do you
do at work I don't know stuff I'm a
level 10 Rogue by the way me and my
buddies you know we're gonna do d d
tonight yeah well like what do you do at
work you know I don't know collate
papers but hey check it out I got this
character I would love to watch that
you're talking about you're talking
about project Veritas garage days
re-revisited no I want to know what girl
was like so committed to figuring out
that she like I'm gonna figure out with
how this game works tell me how the
cards get laid on paper I got it we need
either Freedom Tunes we need like Ryan
long we got the skit the skit is a
Veritas journalist is doing an
undercover sting on a big Tech executive
but they actually fall in love and then
the big Tech guy is like if they find
out I'm dating a Veritas journalist I'll
be fired and she's like if Veritas finds
out I've fallen in love with you I'll be
fired and they they run away in a look
together like Romeo and Juliet someone
call Hallmark right now that's their
next speaker I just want to say like
we're supposed to be talking about this
very serious
this is very serious we're dissecting
you know how to catch these guys right
this is important so for example so for
example do these girls have previous
experience when they apply for this job
or is James training them and what does
the training program look like so it's
like secret spy program someone super
chatted they train them they train them
yeah these these you know young women
get trained on how to get people to talk
about these things how did how do you
like what is this Ted does it look like
Men In Black the movie you were like
you're trying to have them you know take
a test like did you see three four five
on the screen or you know I gotta be
honest it's not that easy to get people
to talk about this stuff you you sit
down for dinner and you say thanks for
meeting how are you you'd warm up a
little bit you say so what do you what
do you do for work and oh I work for uh
Twitter and I'd be like oh cool what's
that like you let them talk you ask like
I was seeing something in the news about
like Congress or something I don't
really follow it and they'll be like oh
yeah there was like bias against
conservatives and then you go oh is that
true like are they doing that that's it
it's not even that difficult
social engineering social engineering at
its finest is what they're doing I mean
I have some level of smarts you can't
just be a complete idiot and take this
but a lot of people they'd be bursting
at the seams what in the talk about
things I see what you're saying and then
when you get somebody that seems like
they're kind of interested and they're
kind of like hey come on something
something yeah then they kind of just
start
letting it go you're that's 100 it must
be it must be very difficult for for
Veritas to train uh these young women to
be manipulative into getting men to give
them what they want you know what I mean
so I want to know if they're like so
have you ever tapped your boyfriend's
phone like how do they screen like what
I'm saying what's your previous
experience yeah they gotta jump they
gotta get jumped in like in the gang
like I need you to go home and I need
you to I need you to put this song I
know what you do I know how to do it
what if what if someone applies for
project Veritas and is also an
undercover journalist trying to you know
yeah double agent here's what I would do
I take all the girls in the room and the
first one to pull some dirt out of the
other girl is the one who gets the job
oh he's got some big brother stuff you
got a surprise him though because you're
gonna you're gonna get like a Washington
Post reporter being like I want to work
and I'm this like you got to figure out
if they're legitimate or not yeah that's
a tough thing yeah but but you know a
Pfizer is looking out for our best
interest let's just call it speed of
spade right this this uh research is
important right yeah it's good for
everyone yeah like the thing that I'm
really interested in finding or
interested in seeing is like what is
this information is anything going to
happen from this like there's already a
significant portion of the population
that doesn't trust uh the the
vaccinations and stuff like that uh
regardless of of what anyone has taken
or has not taken the vaccines it's like
there's a lot of people out there that
are really dead set against it what's
this going to do to you know with the
house being controlled by Republicans
are they going to actually start having
uh um investigations
I mean I gotta say like this actually is
this is real
this is This lends itself more to the
conspiracy that the vaccines actually
are intended to stop the virus this guy
is saying he believes the virus was
essentially manufactured and then
accidentally released yeah and so I've
often talked about that because the
people who are like you know you've got
you've got right now uh that's suddenly
documentary you've got 300 000 excess
deaths in uh I think in young people or
in general in general in the United
States no no I think it's young people
300 000 excess deaths not attributed to
covid and everybody comes out
immediately just says the vaccine and
I'm like well hold on it could be
covered and then people say no they
don't think it is and I'm like yo people
were coming out a year ago two years ago
saying that kovid was a bioweapon
manufactured in a lab that leaked now
y'all are saying no we don't think this
is the cause of people having heart
attacks and stuff like that I'm just
saying I don't know you know I always
say talk to a doctor you know and trust
but don't definitively State you know
one conspiracy theory over another if
like any one of them could be
hypothetical hypothetically plausible or
whatever but yeah I mean I get what
you're saying because
either way you gotta recognize the
correlation that when either or either
one of these things came out
death Spike we saw we we saw the videos
before the vaccine of people collapsing
in the street yeah yeah then we see
people today doing it and they're like
oh that must be the vaccine I'm like why
that was happening before the vaccine
well Scott Adams asked a very
interesting question today right like if
you were on the altar uh alternative
side of things how was I supposed to
know I should listen to you right it's a
very valid question
um we have an internal guy Dr tonight
Ricks he's an organic chemist and
professor and when he said something
about the PCR testing it turned out to
be true he did a threat on this so I
think what it comes down to is you
always need a debate whenever you find
out that there's something that people
don't agree on let's have a debate on
you bring your experts to the table I
bring my experts to the table but what
we found with this conversation was
these experts were the primary source
and everybody else was fake news they
must be banned they must be ostracized
everything yeah
everybody was vilified so that best of
red flag to me like wait I can't have
these doctors cross-examine the work of
your doctors and bring that to the front
and let us make the decision it's the
Alexander Hamilton argument for the
Central Bank where they say no we have
to think for the people because we can't
trust them to make decisions based upon
their own recognizance which has the
inverse of the Streisand Effect
essentially yes you end up with a bunch
of people saying you know what I'm going
to believe the opposite because you
banned it right that's that frustrates
me to be honest because I understand but
it's not Sound Logic to be like they
banned talking about X therefore X must
be true is no no that doesn't follow it
just means the sensors are bad people
yeah and it means they're stifling
legitimate conversation making it harder
for us to figure out what's really going
on but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna take
any tribal side in any of these debates
here's what I did uh I called I did the
only thing a smart person would do when
I got sick as as I called the expert Joe
Rogan right and uh asked him you know he
said call the doctor he said talk to a
doctor so I called I'll private he said
talk to a talk to like a private
practice Yeah and then I did and then we
got monoclonal antibodies yeah we got uh
prescribed that we got prescribed uh
anti-inflammatory like steroids or
something
um what else do we get we got some other
stuff and then we did prescribed
Ivermectin which I said I didn't want I
I attribute the treatment that helped me
monoclonal antibodies and was way better
after that and then didn't even care
about the evermectum but the doctor
insisted that I take it and uh then
Daily Beast wrote a smear about me
saying I was the poster boy forever
mechan when I literally said I didn't
want it I didn't think it did anything I
went on Joe's show and said I don't
think it did anything yeah it's crazy
the problem is you've got corporate
media lying about everything and then
you get a lot of people say if they said
it the opposite must be true and I'm
like well maybe most of the time that
may be the case it'd be completely
honest yeah like the media lies so much
if they come out and say Donald Trump
did a backflip I'd assume he did a front
flip you know and you probably make it
you make more money on your bets if you
go that route I think you have to have
some level of uh ability to manage the
conversation for example if somebody
asks you why why you believe in that you
should have some evidence some
ammunition to back up your claims on you
know why right like if we said something
about PCR tests and the amount of cycles
that they were doing this is what's
creating false positives you sound
something like you know what's going on
right
um but I think a lot of times like you
said people are making that gambling
guess right like this must be true but
you got to look into it you got to know
for yourself what the truth is and why
you know the alternative side might be
right at least have a source and say hey
I don't know the particulars but go talk
to Dr tonight Ricks right if you can't
yeah a doctor like if you can't point
just the expert for other people to say
all right I'm gonna ask him now right
then that's when it's like you can't
even back up what you're saying and it's
a little suspicious and then now the
people who are following the mainstream
can't trust you because you're just
saying oh I'm just going this way
because I'm a conspiracy theorist and
that's banned that's the band opinion no
give people sources they have the meme
you know conspiracy theorists 10 you
know major media zero and stuff like
that and you're like yeah you know for
sure like we totally get that but uh the
thing the thing that people don't
understand is like the doctor you're
referencing you're talking about you're
talking about doctor right you know when
people talk about
um Peter McCullough is that his name
right yeah or Pierre Corey uh doctor
alone we're talking about doctors
doctors have opinions now the problem of
course is they censor these doctors then
you had the front line care doctors like
these are doctors so when I tell people
talk to a doctor that you trust who can
answer the questions and is a medical
professional license and all that stuff
like there are a lot of people who say
yeah but the doctor's so dumb to him and
I'm like look doctors are not one person
if you go to a doctor and they can't
answer any of this stuff they have no
what you're talking about second opinion
well it's not even that it's like bro if
I want here's the analogy I give if I
call a plumbers my toilet broke and then
he goes I got no idea how Plumbing Works
I'd be like okay I gotta hire a plumber
who does yeah if you go to a doctor and
you say hey this is the thing I'm
experienced and I read this and I read
that what is this all about and the
doctor's like I have no idea well dude
like yeah you need to find a doctor who
can tell you about medical ailments and
studies and the research and if you go
to one who can't then it's not like you
went to a doctor you know well that's
how I navigated the Bitcoin world in the
crypto world I didn't know what's going
on I'm not one of those guys so I got
two guys of opposing opinions and had
them debate live in front of me and what
you'll find is this guy will ask that
guy a question and you can tell if this
guy knows what he's talking about even
if you don't understand what he's saying
you can kind of tell by his Mandarin but
if he hits you with the uh well you know
uh then he's like oh wait you can't
answer that question that guy just asked
you and then that's how you can sort of
navigate that conversation not just that
if they can't come terribly admit to a
lack of knowledge is a red flag
conversation you know I was watching uh
I want to give a shout out to uh Lex
Friedman Lex Friedman you know we we've
read on them I've I've watched some of
his Clips but uh the one show of his I
really really want to watch is uh I
guess he did an episode with Daniel
negrano the poker player okay and he's
talking about I've only seen the clips
because I've been watching a bunch of
Poker videos I've been having a lot of
fun playing online poker he's talking
about planting ideas in people's minds
he's talking about trying to figure out
what card somebody has trying to figure
out what they're thinking trying to
figure out if they're playing you and
that is so much of of real life if
you're sitting down and you see two
people and you're like guys is it is is
the left path the right way is the right
path the right way which direction do I
go and one guy says listen
in 1973 the left path was documented as
having more potholes than the ripe now
doesn't mean that today there's still
more potholes but you're better off the
guy on the left says that's not true
that's fake news he's lying he's lying
about potholes okay well which one do
you think makes more sense well this guy
actually cited some some data point I've
not checked it but he's warning me about
puddles this guy's just saying it's not
true yes then you go to the guy on the
left and say okay why do you think
there's no potholes he said there were
he cites this study what do you have to
say uh well uh well the thing is yeah
right there's a red flag because if you
go to the guy on the other side and say
what is he saying about this this thing
not being true he says it was debunked
well look I haven't read any of those
studies suggesting it was debunked you
should probably look it up but I can
only tell you that the studies I've read
said X yeah when someone can confidently
tell you you know what that's a good
point I'm not entirely sure so I
encourage you to follow up that is the
more honest approach yeah of course then
you can get somebody who might try to
manipulate you knowing how to play those
games but that's the word Discerning
politics right like you have to be able
to discern based upon body language
having
uh some level of knowledge on the
subject matter to be able to decipher
the BS from the real right like I don't
know crypto in depth but if you try to
BS me I know when you're bsing same
thing a little bit with health and
biology you know if they start talking
about things if you have a basic
understanding of science sometimes you
can pick apart when somebody's using
words and not saying anything because
you'll get a lot of that yeah shout out
uh you're our resident 2A guy right here
who's that dude who's like he's a
Democrat and he claims he's like I was a
marine you know when we would go out our
our rifles were kept in lockers and blah
blah and he was like an administrator
who wasn't even armed or something like
that yeah you get these people who say
listen I was a marine I can tell you
about guns we have to do it this way and
and then anybody who knows anything
about guns is like this guy is so full I
think people being like Oh while I was
in the military so I know a ton about it
like my older brother was Marine he
regularly was like I I don't know a ton
about guns I know what I learned to go
through training but I am no by no means
an expert for everyone there are people
who weren't military who were just
passionate about the subject and learn
all about it I find that I'm wary when
people start to treat it like you're
supposed to accept it as common
knowledge right so whether it's vaccines
or anything in the whole world like
being like well it's just what everyone
like this is just the way it is this is
just whatever believes oh everyone knows
that and they can't say specifically why
we know that or where it comes from
that's when I start to be like well you
need to present both sides of the
information evidence and sources that's
what we want to see evidence and sources
one side can provide evidence and
sources he's probably more likely to be
believable but the other side always
front ad hominem
emotionalism yeah like they're they're
just trying to discredit you based off
of popular opinion
and then come on and say oh like for
example Neil deGrasse Tyson when he was
was on uh I forgot the podcast Patrick
about yeah on his podcast he was like
well there's a social contract that you
can't go out here and infect people and
basically he was saying then he also
said for lack of a better term he was
like
well basically people are too stupid to
understand the nomenclature so they just
got to take our word for it it's
essentially what he was saying that
whole time yeah I just want to point out
you know I made this joke downstairs the
absurdity of the establishment narrative
and the modern left in that you guys the
hotep crew because of your politics are
white supremacists
oh yeah and then Serge over here the
white guy is an African-American but
like so we talk about it with Luke
gradkowski all the time because he's
Slavic he's polish yeah and they
consider Slavs people of color so if he
came out and supported their ideology
they would quite literally call this
blonde hair blue-eyed man a person of
color then they would call you guys
white supremacists for your political
views yeah like the the logic does not
make sense and I guess in this context
what I'm trying to get to is they don't
even have Arguments for a lot of their
things they have just
they they go to they go to the cult
members and say
someone's like hey I was told the sky is
blue I looked up and the sky was blue
what's happening I thought this guy was
supposed to be green and they go oh it's
green yeah and they go it is it is yeah
don't worry and they go Okay I accept I
accept that you said that to me right
well it works like the court system
where somebody's going to give you a
testimony you have to discredit the
witness they don't actually dispute the
evidence they just discredit the witness
that's that's that's something that you
see a lot like that a lot of times
people on social media they're
performing for the people that are
watching yeah so the actual like it
doesn't matter if they have a lot of
substance in what they're saying it's
can they persuade the the people that
are watching and a lot of times they're
only trying to persuade Their audience
so they know what Their audience is
expecting so if they can go ahead and
deliver the the punch line for Their
audience it's a win for it doesn't
matter if there's actually substance to
the argument yes to your point HJ for
example with this this project Veritas
thing right they're not going to argue
what they heard in the in the video
right what they're going to say is I
can't believe they trapped him like that
yeah I can't believe them on video
hidden camera this is not right they
can't do that that's what they're going
to do they're gonna they're gonna go for
that part of it or although they'll call
you know James O'Keefe for a right-wing
guy right right-wing extremist they'll
put some sort of label some stench uh
some filth on them some stank they put a
little bit of stank on it I like how
James O'Keefe goes after Google and
Pfizer and they're like well that's
right wing he goes after the uh Epstein
story with uh the journalist from ABC
Amy robach they're like well he's a
conservative and it's just like what
about opposing massive corporations big
Tech monopolies pharmaceutical companies
and trafficking Rings is a conservative
position I don't understand it's a weird
thing to claim okay
so Liberals are in favor of big Tech
monopolies big pharmaceutical companies
and Epstein's trafficking ring
it's not liberals anymore it's
authoritarians versus like the Liberals
are the people that are actually you
know four liberal principals the people
that are that are you know against Free
Speech or whatever like that they're
authoritarian let's talk about fake news
and the manipulations because we got
this story from timcast.com McCarthy
removes Schiff swalwell from house
intelligence committee quote I'm
committed to returning the house
intelligence committee to one of genuine
honesty and credibility and uh Mike
cernovich posted this video of Kevin
McCarthy just absolutely wrecking the
media explaining how swalwell there's an
FBI briefing on his association with a
Chinese spy but more importantly Adam
Schiff lied about Russia now Adam Schiff
lied about the hunter Biden laptop
all for political gain and that is why
he is not going to be allowed to get
access to intelligence information in
these committees so Mike servich says
start apologizing because he's he's
going you know he's uh he's bringing the
heat so I'll respect that uh to a
certain degree and say okay you know I
expected McCarthy to do something wasn't
sure how far he'd go let's see how far
he does go but we were just talking
about the manipulators the cult how they
lie and the story of with Adam Schiff is
is is fascinating I pulled up an article
from February of 2018 where he said we
have evidence that Donald Trump colluded
with Russia it's just not publicly
available yet
and so these people just say okay that
proves it yeah as if like he just he
says that turns out guess what no they
didn't have any evidence what does it
say uh live makes it halfway around the
earth before the truth gets his shoes on
yeah that's right Churchill yeah yeah
but you know the second part of that I
added on was but when the truth gets to
choose on oh boy it gets the running
that's a good one I mean not with the
internet especially yeah you know yeah
you know because it's like now you feel
lied to now you feel betrayed so you
know you Empower these people to go out
and like want to spread the truth Goofy
on tight you know loyal to the foil
that's what happens but um it's his
business when you talk about media
you're talking about business they're
not really worried about the welfare of
people they're not concerned with uh
what type of radioactive atmosphere they
could create or tension they just want
to fix them with the clicks they just
want to be first yeah yeah they want to
be first they want the clicks I follow
this one account it tells you every time
uh I think it's the New York Times
changes their headlines or something
like that it's a bot oh wow that's a
good one and I just it makes like
amendments and you see it and you can
see how they're optimizing your
headlines for a higher click-through
rate it's called AB testing yeah so what
these news organizations do
they they've always done this back
before the internet the New York Times
and other newspapers I think the New
York Times but newspapers would send out
two different front pages if Donald
Trump was uh working on say a peace deal
with North Korea
the newspapers in New York would say
Trump Sparks outrage by appeasing North
Korean dictator
and then when the paper gets sent to a
rural area a conservative area I would
say Trump receives High Praise from
conservatives over peace negotiations
with North Korea because it's all about
selling the paper
same story different angle different
framing what they started doing on the
internet they called a b testing where
it's not even about region necessarily
anymore it kind of is if you live in New
York when you see the article and click
it the headline will say you know Donald
Trump does backflip you live in Omaha
you click it Donald Trump does front
flip and they change them in real time
because now they see the fluctuations
and they're like we put out the same
story we put it out with five headlines
here's the rate of Click through per
headline this one did the best then
they'll start moving and changing the
headlines in other areas that's crazy
isn't it and it's and it's framing too
which changes your understanding of the
story right so
timcast.com ran a story a long time ago
that said like Joe Biden criticized for
this thing and I immediately said to the
news team we should not do stories that
are just about someone criticizing Joe
Biden the story should be about what he
did and then we can include reactions so
Joe Biden does backflip not Joe Biden
slammed by conservatives because of
course he's going to get slammed by
cancer no no tell us what's happening
that include the commentary because what
they'll do is you see a story that says
Trump Under Fire for doing backflip and
the average person just hears Trump bad
Trump bad Trump negative everyone's mad
when in reality it could be like under
Fire from two people yeah so but I'll
Trust this doesn't matter if you're if
you're talking opinion pieces I got no
qualms no because I do exactly that yeah
I do my opinion segments and I'll put
Trump slam for this reason because I'm
quite literally opining on my thoughts
I'll be like Joe Biden roasted for doing
this thing and I'll say this is why
people are angry because I'm doing
opinion commentary right but for our
straight new stuff I'm like
just tell us what happened first well I
don't think majority people are even
reading that like they're not clicking
through and seeing the category opinion
op-ed they're not seeing that they're
just seeing the headline so they're just
taking oh this is news and it comes from
a reputable Source or well I mean
reputable back to the context of the
McCarthy stuff Adam Schiff was was using
his position on the intelligence
committee to claim evidence existed that
was you know confidential that the
American people couldn't see yeah and
then they just had to trust him for it
yeah and he was lying so then you get
journalists who write
confirmed evidence exists Trump clue
with Russia and it's like bro some guy
just said that like you saw the Demar
Hamlin thing right right he's at the the
Bills game but he's wearing a hood and a
mask and glasses and he's waving his
arms and you can't see his face yeah the
hollow man is Right hollow man yeah TMZ
says we called and confirmed because
someone told us it was actually him I'm
like but they don't even say who they
call right you didn't confirm anything
did you call his mom he calls agent he
called the actual team I mean this is
right right that's what I think but it's
an escalation into making it all seem
like oh it's common knowledge it's
common knowledge colluded with Russia
and then you can stop questioning it
please don't ask us where our sources
are yeah and that's creepy when Mueller
came out and was like nah what did what
did Schiff and the rest of the Democrats
start saying no no no no no no he said
Trump's not exonerated yes and I'm like
because you don't exonerate people you
have to prove he did it not that he
didn't do it yeah but this is like that
shift's been doing it for as long as
I've been following everything remember
the bombshell witnessed that they had to
keep in witness protection for you know
about Trump nobody ever found out who
that was yeah and they let him do it or
do that he always had some kind of
bombshell or kind of some kind of
Smoking Gun that he could never deliver
on but the mainstream media backed him
they're doing it now the Washington Post
wrote an article defending swalwell and
defending Adam Schiff and I'll give
swallow credit especially because you
know we had Matt Gates on him at this
point he was like look the Fong Fong
thing was well before he was in Congress
so you know I have questions about that
but I'll say this if Kevin McCarthy says
the FBI briefed him saying we have
concerns about this then I'll be like I
don't trust the FBI but if they're going
after a Democrat there must be something
there was this the The Briefing no the
when when he said yeah
when he said at evidence with Russian
collusion what year was Oh 2018 I mean
come on Adam Schiff said it every single
day non-stop the entire time that Trump
was in office they were they were doing
it so yeah well he was clever too he was
clever he'd say things like
he was a I pulled up one interview from
CBS and they're like is there direct
evidence of collusion and you go we have
conversations that have been released to
the public between Donald Trump and
Russian Banks and the Moscow deals that
is direct evidence of collusion and it's
like you see the game he's playing is
he's saying a thing exists that's
already in the public therefore it's
evidence and it's true but you don't
know the thing he's actually referencing
well let me let me let me set the idea
let me set this on fire you ready keep
an eye on the chat
shift did us a favor
you gotta let that one sit let the chat
okay oh my God what is he talking about
build suspense I love it yeah now
everybody's angry now what's the counter
um
Trump didn't win imagine what this
country would look like if Trump ran and
won
I'm gonna tell you right now
this country if Trump would have won
would have been on fire on Flames antifa
would have been everywhere just setting
things up I that's what I feel I feel
like a whole bunch of remember the
summer of black lives matter summer
velocity the summer I love oh man we
didn't have four years of love
that's tough it's tough because there's
there there's there's some truth there
that uh we don't want violence we don't
want destruction and we don't want death
no we don't but at the same time does
that mean you let corrupt people take
over and and run this country into the
ground so you know what we're dealing
with now it was the hard fall or the
slow fall and the question is do you rip
the Bandit off as fast as you can get it
over with yeah or do you slowly peel it
pulling every little hair along with it
yeah that's a tough question and the
question is this if Donald Trump won an
antifa on the far left did go nuts would
Trump have been with his final term gone
in and finally started arresting these
people charging them in mass and
shutting it all down I actually think
that probably would happen I think
Donald Trump was scared to go after
antifung the far left in the Summer of
Love because he was going to run for
reelection he was like they will call me
a fascist it will be weaponized against
me so the strategy I think Trump took
was hey man you live in Portland you
voted for this they can deal with it but
in term two he's like I'm not getting
reelected again send in the Ascend in
the Army National Guard whatever right
yeah you go hard you go hard your last
term you know what I mean yeah do you
think that he had that in him yeah I do
yeah I think he I think I think he had
it in him you know what I mean I think
he had an in them if not he had a hell
of a poker face he'd have bluffed out he
would have bluffed it yeah he'd have
Bluff the heck out of it and they would
have been scared they had to back right
up they'd back right up I guarantee it I
wonder I question
because of the way that he behaved I
question whether he actually did have
the resolve that his that his that is
you know his his uh bolstering scene
yeah you know because he didn't he
wasn't an authoritarian the way that
that a lot of people said that he was
there was a lot of times where there
were a lot of people saying look you
should send the the National Guard in
especially when they were the the people
were rioting in Portland at the uh
um at the courthouse and stuff was at
Seattle or Portland I think it was
Portland yeah it was Portland there's
you know and I think that he was no I
think he was nervous about actually
doing that I think that after the the
issues in DC when he had to be run to
the to the bunker and the way that the
press and media responded to an actual
attack on the White House the way they
responded they were trying to Olympus
his fall in the White House yeah I think
that he was concerned with with using
too much force because he wasn't going
to get any he was going to get he knew
he was gonna get crushed and Donald
Trump wanted to be liked more than
anything in the world this is this is
the problem that Trump had he's not
Machiavellian you know when the 529
Insurrection happened antifa shows up
the White House and tried to Olympus was
it Olympus Has Fallen Olympus Has Fallen
yeah the rod Butler movies when uh so I
say this all the time
if Donald Trump ordered the law
enforcement to stand down
and antifa then ripped the fences down
and torched Saint John's Church
it would have shifted The Narrative of
this country 180 degrees he would be in
the bunker he would come out the next
day to a destroyed historic American
Church the White House being rampaged by
far left extremists and he would say the
attack on this country by the far left
extremists is unprecedented not since
the 1890s or whatever 1880s has the
White House been attacked before has a
historical church been set a flame
he could say something like
the fear that we had as good stewards of
the Constitution was that to send out
law enforcement to shut down what was
what had begun as a peaceful protest
would be an affront to the rights of
every American citizen if only we had
known the violence the hatred and the
danger that was far left extremism then
we would have taken action but we
believed in the American people and the
right to protest and unfortunately the
the extremists in the far left and
antifa exploited that to destroy iconic
American you know you don't you don't
think the leftist media would have spun
that
you can't spend St John's Church torched
and Raised To The Ground by the far left
the problem is
how did you spin it it's the left I'll
put nothing past them maybe like he
deserved that and the church
and you're right yes but think about the
Suburban housewife who's seeing
smoldering ruins from far left
extremists is that the target demo
you're saying of this speech we're not
trying to convince the far left in the
corporate press to vote for anybody yeah
see but the thing is Donald Trump is not
Machiavellian he said hey they're
they're trying to burn a church down
stop them quick and they did but but
would that Mom get the Donald Trump
speech or would she get a contorted
version of that from far left is Media
you're you're not wrong about that yeah
but I'm talking about weight right okay
when when far left extremists set fire
to St John's Church and they did yeah
set fire to a guard post the White House
and and tore down the barricades
injuring I think like a hundred plus Law
Enforcement Officers Trump shut down and
The Narrative of the media was Trump
attacks peaceful president so you're
saying you should have let it go let it
happen I'm not saying he should have
you're saying if he did the
Machiavellian manipulative you know uh
evil way to deal with it and that's what
I'm saying I'm saying Trump's not an
evil guy right Trump said hey they're
trying to hurt people and burn this
thing now we better stop them yeah the
media spun that against them yeah what
I'm saying is wait if antifa goes and
antifa set fire to Saint John's Church
and the media defended them yeah now
what would happen if the church was
raised to the ground it would be a lot
harder to defend them I see what you're
saying yeah that whole oh you know
mostly peaceful where everything burning
in the background or hit a lot harder
yeah when you got a historic church in
rubble in rubble you know versus a
church that almost went down and you got
Trump in front of it holding his Bible
right where they spawn it like oh he had
his Bible upside down I'll tell you what
they do the left would come out and say
the failure of Donald Trump's
Administration to stop the violence is
shocking how could he let this happen
and then Trump could come out and say
you're absolutely right we should have
gone harder and used the military and
the National Guard to stop the violent
far-left extremists but we didn't want
to hurt our fellow Americans but I
confess I was wrong to try and be
peaceful and and maintain the peace it
backfired Tim you you'd make a good
press secretary you're about to say
Trump we should have had you writing his
speeches bro oh Michael may I also make
a good press can we do iro live from the
White House Press Room every night when
my big truck gets reelected you know
this is the crazy thing to me because
like you look at January 6th yeah
January 6 is exactly what I'm talking
about okay where were the police right
why is there a video of a guy walk up to
cops saying please stop them look he's
pointing to the people walking what are
you doing and the cops are like nope why
are there cops on video opening the
doors and letting people in and then the
Democrats saying oh no we were attacked
it's an Insurrection and they ran that
narrative for a year and they just
started an investigation they impeached
Trump because of it that's what I'm
saying I'm saying Trump didn't have the
the moral failings to do what Democrats
did yeah because yeah January that day
in January
they didn't so he he allegedly he asked
for 10 000 troops the uh the Guardsmen
to be there yeah allegedly allegedly
Nancy Pelosi said no thank you we don't
want the Optics of that yeah
I think she want the opposite of that
because she got the Optics that she
wanted yup yeah far right extremists
and think think about what would happen
if I tell you if on 529 Donald Trump
start was rushed into the Into the
Bunker under under the White House he
was and if he said listen the last thing
we want is a dead protester on the news
stand down and then the protesters
ransacked everything yeah the D Trump
would have been been reelected
guaranteed and then he was at the doj
after all of the far left just like
they're doing to the January six people
he'd be going after and rooting out far
left cult members and violent extremists
instead what do we get right now in
Atlanta
far left extremists are from out of
state crossing state lines with
semi-automatic weapons occupying a
forest shooting cops and putting them in
the hospital calling for the
assassination of police and then
ransacking downtown Atlanta so burning
people's homes and torching a guy's
vehicle that's all happening it's not
stopping it keeps going and we were
surprised
you mean there was an autonomous Zone in
Georgia for the past two years or
whatever and they're burning houses to
the ground and vehicles and one guy shot
a cop yep and the media is protecting
them uh so I'm just over here doing
Italian counting up all the grifters
that we're going I made for the grifties
go to grifties.com nominate your
favorite grifter I see what's the dude's
name from faza that was on the date
Grifton trying to grift his job on a
date Griffin Chris Walker Tristan Jordan
Tristan Jordan Tristan Walker yeah we
got to nominate him somebody go to
distance I've got nominate him what's
this guy's name
um
we gotta nominate him nominee
yeah because because look a lot of
people will say like they'll be like for
the Griffey it's got to be you know uh
Stephen Crowder or Jank Euchre or Tim
Poole it's like well I I get that you
don't like the commentators but Adam
Schiff yeah as a politician that's a
good one a lot of people mix up the
fancy Pelosi a lot of people mix up the
meaning of the word Griff though because
like a lot of people think that like
they just someone they don't like is a
grifter it's like they'll use that term
interchangeably and like grifting is a
it's a very loose term well we use it
you know the the there's a uh if you
watch the grifties tomorrowgrifties.com
you'll see it we have a different
definition that we like to go with but
what we like to say is Loosely there's a
light side in this dark side if
somebody's taken away from the Griffin
and somebody like you know we be Grifton
we Griffin right now yeah I mean we
grifted off a 10 pool shout out to Tim
cast iron you know everybody's grifting
to some level it's just more like what
are your intentions what's your end game
what are you doing with this all are you
trying to push inoculations on people or
are you trying to free Mine right sure
but at the end of the day everybody's
got a grift right but you're right
sometimes people use the word you just
say I don't like this person he's a
grifter it's just like but it sort of
implies like conning someone you know
what I mean yeah selling them snake oil
yes that's always been my understanding
of it yeah someone that it's like a
sellout an opportunist like they see
something they jump on the message right
like they don't know if they believe I
mean my prime example this is AOC when
she took those pictures crying at the
border
it was like that's the dark side that's
the dark side of the no yo that's prime
time grifting you know what I mean you
guys phenomenal you got to do like
little montage videos where it's like
the top ten and it's like Alexandria
ocasio-cortez and it shows like a
slow-moving photo and then it shows her
like crying at the border and it shows
her on the phone going where is she
where is she it's playing like you know
orchestral music
she made that story up it was fake yeah
yeah now that is grifting right there
the question you gotta you gotta be a
special kind of look I I would not want
to play AOC in poker because she well
actually I'll take that back I can see
through her Bluffs but she would do
really really well
bald-faced lie when she's like they come
to my door and bang and I'm hiding in
the bathroom and I hear where is she
it's like yo that happened an hour
before the the building was even
breached so before anybody entered the
building someone knocks on her door and
she's hiding in the bathroom get out of
here she made that up you know it was a
cop looking forward to evacuate the
building she made it up you know she'd
be grateful Janes will keep Spa programs
but she's you know I say she'd be good
at pokers because she can lie to your
face yeah without with without twitching
without with no tell you'd be like
because she feels like her lies are just
but I'm obviously I've never met her I
don't know but like there are some
people who feel as though like they are
entitled to lie like their means are so
honorable that they don't feel remorse
like people who Flinch when they lie or
give some tell like they feel on some
level guilty about I don't think they
believe that they're lying well that's
true too I really think that there are
people that there are people like
narcissistic yeah it's Saul alinsky's
rules for radical yes right it's like
yeah I might be lying but I'm doing it
for good yeah it's what it's what is the
goal yeah that's in mind and justifies
the means what's that mean where they
have the woman crying with the snap
bubbles coming out said women can lie
this hard I mean people can cry it's
hard and still be lying
they commit I don't know what to tell
you yes it is what it is I mean think
about that with like Nancy feels like if
it's true that she had the chance to
have 10 000 National Guards members at
the Capitol that day and she was like no
we don't need them like I spent uh I was
at opening Arguments for Enrique tario
and the proud voice trial and they are
the federal government was like yeah we
have fbm
foreigners be like okay they should
explain why there was no law enforcement
if you think this was a planned
Insurrection where was everybody if you
guys knew you didn't defend anything I
mean it just becomes to the point where
you're like is Nancy Pelosi grifting for
this long-term play at the White House
like it's I think this is what puts
Americans off of politics right you want
to believe in The Honorable but you are
shown time and time again that people
operate for their own good like even the
Pfizer video the guy is saying like well
we could make money off of this this
could be good for us but then we'll do
is turn around and tell you that Donald
Trump did a passenger 57 in the back of
the limo trying to take out some secret
service agent well real quick let me get
my grift on because I'm getting news
right now that my camera's a little dark
somebody said my light isn't right so I
just want to chat help me out this does
Temple have racist cameras does he have
those what is it remember HP like their
cameras wouldn't focus on black people
there was like a campaign they did where
they're like our new cameras for all
skin tones yeah a bunch of black people
yeah I didn't know I just want to make
sure chat let let's search now let's
surge know if my camera's good I gotta
look good man griffy's tomorrow well
it's you're wearing a black shirt with a
black backdrop oh that's what it is yeah
oh man you always gotta bring the race
grift up man cut it out listen I'm a
black supremacist damn it one time we
were uh doing a show and Tim was like
you're too white you're throwing off the
color balance in here I don't know so
maybe it's just like any extreme part of
the skin tone well alcohol tips like
white women
who doesn't
I don't know
nobody on the planet just for the record
nobody in the planet hates black people
more than Uncle Hotel oh my gosh he's
here hi Uncle tip the black the black
white supremacist I've been following
Uncle hotep for a lot of years have you
oh yeah oh yeah I followed him before I
followed you
yeah you know you know what's up man
that's terrible I put you on him that's
the question I don't I don't know I
followed him on YouTube I watch his
YouTube channel
um but I'm I'm not sure exactly why do
you like this guy because he makes me
laugh he's funny I'm honest down to per
down the Earth I'm a black man from
extra Pennsylvania
just a black man from Exeter
Pennsylvania
he's a grifter that's what he is Yo Tim
your invitations are are spot on man did
you practice that man which one which
imitation both of them are pretty good
pretty good what'd he do he did Trump
and he did uh Trump was not a real
impersonation that was you had it for a
couple the first couple sentence you had
it yeah Trump's actually I can't do
Trump at all so I just do like a little
bit of the like he talks in a very weird
way the fouchy thing is I'm actually
trying to do cartoon versions of them
okay so like the fouchy voice that I do
is intended to be an over-the-top
exaggerated version of fauci you don't
need to be wearing two masks so it's
like it's gruffer it's you know and then
Nancy Pelosi when I do her I over
emphasize her teeth she talks like this
is Donald Trump it's the worst man in
this country that's why Nancy Pelosi so
it's like it's it's kind of cartoony I
feel like you need more lip smacking in
the Pelosi
I bet if I actually tried and like
actually practiced I probably could do a
bunch of really good ones absolutely
yeah yeah but I was the voice of fauci
for Freedom tunes for a while that was
that was fun oh that's dude but then
when Fati was out of the news Sheamus
didn't need me on the show anymore so I
just yeah the classic grifter Sheamus
we did we did a bit where uh you guys
saw the story that said if you're not
vaccinated you're more likely to get in
a car accident do you see that one let's
talk about Grifton man but so Sheamus
did a bit where fauci's snipping car
breaks
[Laughter]
yeah yeah all right all right I guess
we're going to talk about war because we
do have this one pulled up and it's not
funny and I'm kind of like reluctant to
pull it up because we're laughing here
we're making fun of people and now we
have the story where it's like the
world's gonna end take us out from the
guardian U.S joins Germany in sending
tanks to Ukraine as Biden Hale's United
effort president land's unflagging
commitment to Ukraine as officials
approve 31 M1 Abrams Tanks to add to
Germany's 14 leopard to a6s
is this world war three I mean you don't
gotta call world war three but I mean
NATO is at war with Russia this is not
Ukraine I mean we are the ones it's fair
it's fair to say it's escalation
I mean I I don't I mean Russia says it's
world war three right they already used
that term they're they're already well
they're TV personalities all over Russia
are saying we're on World War Three
already one guy came out again it's like
the fifth time some TV personality has
done it and said fire the nukes already
just start firing nukes the the the fact
that there's tanks being given to
Ukraine that is going to be
justification to the Russians to
escalate they're going to say the that
NATO is escalating because it's Germany
and the U.S they're going to look at it
in France they're going to look at it
like an escalation and they're going to
do something there will be some response
every time we do anything that helps
Ukraine Russia takes that as an attack
on them and they use that as
justification to do more things so y'all
I don't know what they're starting are
we really helping Ukraine by prolonging
the war though I don't think so but
that's just me it's a question of are we
are we preventing Russia from taking
more control of Ukraine is that is that
help I kind of think the U.S I look at
this way Ukraine is a border country
with Russia right the United States is
on the other side of the planet and the
U.S is sending weapons and agitating
imagine if Russia was sending weapons to
Mexico and then like cartels were
attacking the southern border and trying
to take stretches of the Rio Grande or
something well Russians are the black
people of white people
what is that what does that what does
that mean
no I mean look woke people say Slavic
people are are people of color yeah well
I mean that's technically you're right
like even look at it from a resource
perspective you know Russia's the Africa
of Europe
they're very minimal rich
right like oil like very big yeah that
cold though yeah so if you look at how
Rush uh how Africa is treated Russia is
getting the Africa treatment we got to
go in we gotta colonize we have to take
your assets we have to divvy it up it's
just beautiful communism you think we're
gonna go into Russia too you know the
U.S goes into Russia I well when you say
into Russia right it's it's
first thing now we have to understand
what
colonizing what you first do is you
colonize the culture
and as we talked about before you
discredit the witness so you discredit
the current culture you make Putin look
bad you make the culture and then you
attack the root
of Russia which is Orthodox Christianity
they're already attacking that so
there's a cultural colonization that's
happening and if you can uproot that
everything else sort of falls into place
but Russia is definitely a target of
some group of people on this planet most
of them running financial institutions I
believe because they're the same ones
behind situations like FTX right large
financial institution pumping into and
then I didn't say that you said that
um
but we saw the financial institutions
that were involved in the FTX election
Ukraine
triangle you see what I'm saying but
there's always been that sort of history
between America and Russia for example
we talk about uh the Civil War
the North had Russia as an ally so
there's always been that tie right also
I mean that that Britain too didn't they
no
uh that was uh the South had a
France and Britain against them against
them right oh you said the North had
Russia against them had Russia with them
with them but but then France and the UK
were with the north as well South
the the the UK and France were with the
South correct okay well they were like
they were like playing both sides right
trying to see well absolutely yeah yeah
yeah they were selling stuff I think I
think actually yeah I think the South
was trying to sell cotton to the UK
mm-hmm correct yeah yeah yeah yeah so
there was some of that and Russia comes
in and plays this role as hey we're
going to be the great equalizer of some
sort and that's how we get the whole
exchange of Alaska because they own that
and that's how that thing happens right
correct but you got to remember Russia
was a world superpower under uh Nicholas
right that was before the Russian
Revolution came about and who financed
the Russian Revolution I say on here but
everybody knows who did that right so
you see this tie of money behind all
these things real quick this is from my
book The Patriot report I'm asking a
conspiracy of money award available now
on Amazon and hoteljesus.com
um but I've tracked back you know this
whole thing about the central banking
system whatever whatever but I always
see Russia pop up and I see Russia as
being the one place that this financial
Elite has not quite conquered so I think
they want to it and then you
know slowly grab its resources
if you take a look at uh history of the
region with the Middle East with Europe
one big component which it's interesting
because I hear in the media they're
reporting as a conspiracy theory it's
the the natural gas Monopoly it's gas
prom it's Nordstrom it's the cutter
turkey pipeline I talk about it all the
time because it's like I think it's the
key in what's happening NATO wants to
get cheap energy into Europe Europe
demands it Syria says no the U.S is is
very fortunate that Syria then goes into
Civil War and of course we oppose the
Assad regime who said outright we will
not let you build the cutter turkey
Pipeline and uh conveniently wanted to
build an alternate pipeline that would
do the same thing strengthening Russia's
energy Monopoly in Europe and then all
of a sudden you get barisma with Joe
Biden former CIA director and these
interests working for an energy company
in Ukraine
nordstream 2 blows up you can just
imagine stink bug did you yeah you're
going to regret that yeah absolutely
it's gonna smell real bad now
Chinese books it is that's what you
don't you know you can't smash them bro
really yeah it's gonna be like ammonia
here in a minute yeah it's Mel yeah it
smells like ammonia is that what it is
it's like are we just wrestling today
that smells like cilantro it doesn't
smell like cilantro no it's it's gonna
smell real bad though yeah yeah they
release this oil
stink bugs man yeah they're called stink
bugs oh that's what they call those
that's the thing I call the Chinese bugs
they are Chinese bugs right yeah they
came over here in the 70s or whatever
and they're you can't get rid of them
right yeah yeah we actually uh we looked
it up it's 1996 oh 96 well yeah you uh
we called the Exterminator sprang does
nothing yeah because in China they have
wasps that eat them but you don't have
lobster yeah there's no natural predator
yeah anyway we're talking about we're
talking about Nordstrom too that
Nordstrom tube blows up yeah and then
right you know they blame Russia for
blowing up their own Pipeline and it's
like yeah Putin did it yeah so it's so
it the the whole thing is
it's interesting because the argument
made about why the EU needs to exist is
to compete with China that's what they
say they say they want to create a
powerful economic block they can compete
with China because China is growing so
rapidly I call BS on that Joe Biden was
involved in selling natural gas from
Louisiana to China with Hunter Biden
that was just revealed in the hunter
Biden laptop story exclusive emails
released Daily Mail covered the story
Joe Biden there's an email saying I've
organized the meeting for Joe and Hunter
to do the sale and it was natural gas
from Louisiana to China why are we
selling energy to China
so they say Europe wants to compete with
it I call BS I think it's
ideological I think it is control I
think you got a bunch of powerful
interests the United States went to
China
and said what you're doing with this
communism using Market Market systems
dictatorship is what that what we want
to do so the United States has been
trying to implement Chinese style
communism here and in other countries
it's a lot more than just that I don't
think it's so simple I think energy
absolutely plays a role they do want to
get cheaper energy into Europe they do
want lower energy costs but Russia is
their principal villain not China China
has the ideology they like Russia
doesn't what's the incentive for Biden
and the rest of these guys to go along
with the Chinese agenda
are they thinking about themselves or is
it some I think what you basically have
is there's evil people who do things for
ideological reasons okay who employ
selfish psychotic individuals who do
things for personal reasons okay so Joe
Biden's the kind of guy who says I'm
gonna sell energy to China everyone else
be damned and then you have ideologues
who are like who are they the ideologues
yeah I it's hard to say who is who is
they though right yeah
it's hard to say because I'm walking out
of here man we made it an hour in
everybody he's the new record holder so
the reason I say it's hard to say is not
that it's a censorship question and
people expect me to say like Jews or
something no I'm talking about like the
Davos group okay powerful corporate
interests these are people of all
different backgrounds there you can call
them Global Elites you can call them uh
CEOs you could but it's hard to quantify
exactly how you group these people other
than it is the people of means and power
around the world who don't want to lose
use it who birds of a feather flock
together they have big big business big
business big business big government
uh all that kind of stuff big lizard
maybe maybe even lizards yeah we don't
know but but a lot of people say the
world economic Forum the Davos group
yeah and it's like that's that's
simplistic that's where a lot of the I
think the employees hang out I would I
would say you know some people have said
like it's the Illuminati as a catch-all
term for powerful Global interests I'd
say that it is a semi-emergent
phenomenon meaning I don't think that
there is like the order of the
Illuminati you know that actually meets
and sits down at their meeting was a big
sense as Illuminati what I think it is
is a Hydra
you've got all these big corporations
they are interested in maintaining that
power and that power is maintained
through rigid control of the of the
planet which means Henry Kissinger I
think Ian points out limited Warfare
meaning they want some more they sell
weapons they don't want to know War
so there's a there's a degree of control
they have to have in a lot of things
they don't have total control though
they're just special interests and the
reason I say semi-semia Merchant is
emergent meaning a phenomenon that
happens over time naturally and I say
only semi because you certainly have
powerful special interests who will meet
and say hey
we need to move these tanks what are we
doing it's like salmon Ukraine let's get
it let's get a conflict up I mean look
at the stock for the companies that
operate the stuff now I'm not saying
definitively that conspiracy theory is
true I'm saying yeah there absolutely
are powerful CEOs who meet with
government officials and say we've got
to move shirts out of this country what
can we do and the government says look
we'll work I have this beautiful War
laid out for you I think maybe that's a
little far but but I'll I'll give a
shout out to Matt Gates
who said
I said you're going to get a bill to
break a big Tech and then they're gonna
you know get put options on he goes that
actually happened they had a bill moving
through Congress to break up big Tech
Paul Pelosi bought the dip and then the
bills died in their tracks wow and then
of course the stock goes up that's the
kind of thing I'm talking about it's not
that's not an emergency I'll just
introduce the Pelosi act to stop uh
exactly yeah yeah I've seen that but
here here what ultimately what I think
is this
CEO of a Fortune 500 company he's trying
to sell as many vaccines as possible he
hears he he lobbies the government give
us a guaranteed contract and the
government says
let's talk you're gonna get lobbies so
let's talk right they're gonna this is
what the this came out of the Veritas
thing just now the uh the guy was saying
basically I think this came out of the
Veritas thing you think these government
employees who are regulating big Pharma
are going to be mean to them when
they're expecting a job afterwards right
the lobbyist doesn't just say I'll
donate to your campaign he says you know
we're big fans of the work you do we
know you believe in helping people of
the world maybe once you're uh you know
what you retire you know we could talk
about a nice package maybe there's a fit
for you come on the board maybe maybe a
couple million dollar a year salary if
of course we think that you actually
care about this stuff yeah that what
ends up happening then is
the guy who takes over this company this
big Pharma company
he's not inducted into a conspiracy he
doesn't go to a meeting and they sit him
down and they make him walk through
paddles and he gets veeden or whatever
he's a guy who gets the company and he's
told hey if you want to make that
billion dollars this year and get your
25 million bonus we gotta sell more
product is there a way we can get the
government the biggest buyer to buy it
which is possible let's send the
lobbyists to convince them mandates are
the way to go yeah and then you get
these things so you're a communist me
I mean you just basically said that this
is uh you know capitalist greed
that's like that's corporatism yeah it
says corporate greed
Corp yeah I don't know I don't know if
you say this about making money I called
it an emergency but we got a move
products isn't it fascism no no hold on
hold on this is important I don't think
I don't know if greed is the word used
to describe it that's why I say it's
it's an emergent phenomenon right it's
power too but look at this way
it's it's because you said bonus you
said bonuses is a financial incentive
there but it's not the human machine
it's the it's the it's the uh it's
beyond the human machine man no no no no
no timcast.com is a company yeah
timcast.com needs a certain amount of
money every week to maintain this
company right the person who is trying
to maximize Tim cast product isn't
thinking I want to myself he's thinking
I need to meet these deadlines in kpis
exactly so in order to do that and do my
job I might need to call somebody in
government so you get big Pharma and
it's not necessarily the CEO saying I
want to make a billion dollars for
myself yeah but the bonus plays a role
obviously I mentioned that a lot of it
is the Guy saying look we're looking at
a down forecast our Stock's gonna take a
hit the shareholders are going to get
pissed yeah we gotta figure out a
revenue stream and someone says look
this covet thing
there's talk of mandates we should be on
that 100 percent it's the right thing
for the people and it'll help us secure
contracts to keep the company running
yeah and then Tristan walks and he goes
I got a great idea what we're going to
do is we're going to create a whole
bunch of multivariant mutant viruses and
we can sell more vaccines it is how many
grains of sand make a heap is the
banality of evil it is people like him
who are saying
they're justifying it to themselves but
you know what the reality is some of
these people know what they're doing is
evil they know they are cogs in a
machine that is destructive but my point
ultimately is when it comes to the
entirety of the the system as it's
orchestrated yeah I do not believe there
is a singular group of people or
individual who's sitting there saying
throwing this mustache being like yes
how we're going to take over the world
it people come and go it's a it's a
monster it's an amorphous blob empowered
by all of the different people who say
look
I'm not an avalanche I'm just a
snowflake Avalanche was coming long
before I got here that's what I see the
Avalanche doesn't blame itself I'm sorry
the snowflake doesn't blame itself for
the Avalanche but each and every time
some Global leader or some powerful
executive joins in these meetings and
they say two things happen the
ideological pressure and the economic
pressure one how do I meet my deadlines
to make sure my company doesn't fail
because of shareholders the employees
are counting on me government mandated
contracts two is the ideological
pressure you ever hear that story so let
me ask you a question real quick let me
just sorry I'll finish this point you
ever hear that story they did where they
put a bunch of chips and chips in a room
they put a ladder in the middle room
with fruit on top chimp walks over
there's five chimps climbs the ladder
fire hose comes out sprays them all the
chimps get sprayed down
chip climbs tries climb the ladder again
boom they all get sprayed down they
learn stay the away from that ladder
they take one chimp out they put one
Chimp in new chimp is looking around
like what am I doing in here walks over
to the ladder the other chimps run up
grab them and throw them down and start
beating him up because he's gonna get us
sprayed right one by one they replace
all the old chips
now they got five chimps who have never
been sprayed with the fire hose any one
of them goes near that ladder they get
beat up why that's the way we do things
yeah that's I think a large component of
the ideological capture that happens
with people at the top so you're saying
that there's this corporate
fascism thing phenomenon that you
mentioned right
and I don't want to dispute that but who
killed JFK
I don't know
it was Charlie he said it was a CIA
Charlie
wow he then went on to say did he say
that they went after Nixon too because
he was trying to figure out who killed
JFK Tucker's been going off yeah but
yeah I think he knew there was something
in the files or something like that so
how does all that tie in right if we got
the corporate thing happening in
Temple's phenomenon why is the CIA you
know these other groups involved in are
they part of that corporate thing or are
these not just corporates government
power so here's what happens why does
the CAA get formed it's it's my my fear
is that people ascribe to conspiracy
that which is an emergent human
phenomenon which is dangerous that we
need to recognize the power power
coalescence
so you get you know the FBI I think uh
what did the FBI start as I forgot I did
this whole thing researching it before
was the FBI was called something else
right look at what it is today yeah
right I mean people don't start these
things intending them for intending for
them to become monsters yeah but they do
so you think there's people like struck
maybe in position of power who are
abusing this power absolutely okay if
you like it I think what I mean to say
is there are people there there's we'll
call it the the the super liminal the
limit on the subliminal you know as The
Simpsons joke reference there are people
who know they're bad people and want
power but I think that's there's not
that many of them there's a lot and you
don't need that many in positions of
power to get an evil group of people
destroying the world you then have
people who know that what they're doing
is kind of bad but they think I'm more
powerful here for good even though so I
remember hearing about like the CEO of
shell or something telling activists I
want to save the world too I'm more
effective as the CEO in doing good so
they recognize in their own mind yeah
bad things are happening because of what
I do but I'm trying and then you have
the people who are totally oblivious who
are like everybody get on the freight
freight car I got no idea why you're
going there where are you going there
but I'm Gonna Make sure you do yeah and
they're contributing to that evil
that's crazy
that's absolutely insane bro
so
I'm trying to put all those pieces
together you don't think that there's a
board table uh of Illuminati that are
making decisions behind the scenes
the answer to that question is how do
you think they got a group chat and they
say hey what are we going to do now
they're on top hold on hold on hold on
the answer to that is half yes okay of
course there's a board meeting where
powerful rich people are meeting up but
there's no induction there's no name you
know how they always throw out the name
like Rockefellers yeah of course of
course Rothschild but that just means
rich people and wealthy families and
those Rich families have changed you now
have Jeff Bezos who owns the Washington
Post he wants to sell it so is he an
Illuminati if you're if you're saying
Illuminati as in a nebulous idea of the
powerful Elites who control the planet
yes absolutely oh Jeff Bezos Illuminati
okay what about Elon Musk I would say
yes
so okay so we have Bill Gates I think we
could throw him in there oh absolutely
okay Bezos is Zuckerberg in there yes
yes yeah yeah yeah what about Jack
Dorsey Jack Dorsey I'd say yes
absolutely really even after but but you
got to understand it there's not a
membership list right we're using
Illuminati as a vague term to represent
the most powerful people in the world
okay who meet with each other and decide
how to move their chessboard pieces of
course all these people are playing the
game are there good guys and bad guys
yes yes Elon Musk is in an interesting
position is he a good guy or a bad guy
that's tough to say he's got factories
in China he's defended China he's posted
good things about the Chinese Communist
party but in the United States he says
good things about Freedom he pushes back
he uh you know on the establishment he
calls out Democrats so a lot of people
in the U.S are cheering Free Speech Free
Speech yay but what about his business
dealings in China yeah I mean I mean
we're not We're not gonna sit here and
defend the Chinese Communist party but
Elon Musk has said nice things about
them then you gotta look
powerful people
whether whether they intend to or not
make big moves yeah big moves yeah so
when I say Zuckerberg Gates what I'm
basically saying is at the cream of the
crowd at the top of the top these people
birds of a feather flock together
they're going to hang out they're going
to have similar ideas and similar
experiences they may not completely
agree but they can move mountains so
when we see big moves happening people
on the bottom say it's a conspiracy
they're plotting and it's like
technically that's true right wealthy
powerful and corporate government Elites
are meeting together are planning things
together but it's not like they wear
dark robes and draw pentagrams on the
ground and then paddle each other to to
induct them into this illumination while
they're making the decisions that kind
of party happens after the decisions are
made but don't get me wrong there there
are those weird parties that happen
that's what I mean it's what I'm saying
is there may be groups that go to like
Bohemian Grove do that weird Malik stuff
yeah which I'm sure you've heard of but
the people the Davos group people things
like that I know people who have gone to
the world economic Forum they do not
regularly go to board meetings they go
once a year to hear what other people
have to say yeah share their ideas but
if you get 2 000 corporate Elites and
government Elites and they all start
sharing their ideas together it starts
to starts to come together their Cycles
start to synchronize if you know what I
mean you know you know who some people
say is an Illuminati oh temple in the
Illuminati yeah they say you're part of
this group
of evil decision makers are you an
Illuminati template I'm putting you on a
spot right now nope nope uh I'm not I
guess unfortunately because I thought I
was about to ask you well can I get in
no no
interesting things happening with the
decentralization of power and media and
resources so now you're ending up with
companies that probably much to the
Chagrin of these uh uh powerful Elites
who want to control things you're
getting people like us who are finding
ways to navigate through the cracks and
build power that is very hard for them
to deal with so you're building like an
ALT Illuminati yeah well no but maybe we
should I did say this on the show before
I was like can't we do the opposite can
we have like a group of activists come
together for meritocracy Liberty
personal freedom personal responsibility
and then start like making books and
giving them to schools and doing stuff
like that you know what I mean well
Hotel Nation that's what we're involved
with homeschooling well I believe in
homeschooling but I'm saying make the
hotel book and get it and get it in
schools you talk about counter
propaganda
or just literally propaganda yeah
Freedom propaganda yeah I like that idea
you guys make the books go to schools
and then tell the schools like you're
not racist are you you're not okay then
put our book in your curriculum the book
will be like Freedom Liberty personal
responsibility Uncle Hotel what would
you put in a book if we were to put a
book out
and say this is the most important thing
we want to tell people or teach children
you know especially with CRT drag story
time right now what would you put in a
book
what would I put in a book yeah like
what would be you know the one thing you
think children need to need to be taught
to because I look at it as like counter
Marxism right
because that's really what's
counter-revolutionary yes yeah
absolutely you're now you're talking my
language yeah you know what they need to
put in the grifter Hall of Fame hotep
Jesus number one there tomorrow right
there thegrifties.com greatest grifter
of all time vote for me thriftys.com do
you nominate yourself you're like I have
to be on this list yeah that's awesome
I'm in the site I got access of course I
found it on myself I'm trying to win I
think I just got passed by um
Dan can you pull it up grifties.com can
you pull up who's winning right now
again
pull that up and what's happening yeah
grifties.com gr i f t i e s
no uh take out the it's just grifties oh
it's no the no the yeah put put that up
there let's see who's winning right now
Eliza blue no that's the news
Eliza blew at 14.
you're number two oh
who's Chile de Castro I don't know The
Young Turks number five I'm impressed oh
no no that says what is that says newest
nominees number five what does that mean
all because they're groups is that what
it is yeah it is groups yeah okay Nation
hotep's been told you you guys are
trying the grifties is number one let's
go that's a good one Reddit look at this
gratitude and Greta that's impressive
hotel with it Alex Stein number nine
Crowder number ten Eliza blue is there
at number 14 is a new entry Vladimir
zelenski at 12. uh Michael rapaport's in
there gruesome news look at that all
right I was on there at one point I was
pretty high up there but I guess I got
knocked off you gotta nominate Temple
nominate Temple right now on
grifties.com I don't know if I deserve
it to be honest absolutely absolutely
you do you deserve it because I'm able
to grift off of you
you make grifting capable or possible
for a lot of people you've got to be
acknowledged for your contribution
amplification culture the grift economy
next year I might be able to make it I I
do think I gotta be honest I don't know
if you should be number two why I should
be number one right no I don't know if
you should be on the list at all why
because I think making the grifties and
talking about it is not grifting
I think it's the griftiest thing in the
world to re to win the grifties when you
made it yourself that's actually a good
point wait wait make that point again
actually I should
because what because as you made this
thing but actually that's a good thing
you're trying to win your own thing is
the griftiest thing yeah that's the best
normally you recuse yourself because
it's your competition but in this case
all right we're gonna have to be in it
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member over at
timcast.com because we're gonna have
that members only show coming up for you
in about an hour uh hour and a half or
so it goes up around 11 p.m and uh
generally we just appreciate your
support your membership at timcast.com
makes all of this operate helps us work
smash that like button and let's uh
let's see what you got
Smokey Joe says speaking of body doubles
Christine Collins boy went missing in
1928 LAPD returned a boy that wasn't
hers then told her to try the boy out
and had her institutionalized when she
refused the boy yo what I've heard that
story before yo that's crazy wild
Cassius Camp says hotep or die Tim hit
me up if you need an intro
intro they're here they're sitting right
next to me let's do it do you mean like
an intro to the show yeah he makes music
Cassius makes music yeah we should have
a theme oh right on yeah yeah all right
let's see we got here what is this sound
the cash is Cam
he makes the email the intro the hotel's
been told you oh okay right on yeah
Tyler Bratton says I have a suspicion
that this guy is a whistleblower the way
he said don't tell anybody made it seem
like he knows he's being recorded I
could be wrong but nonetheless thank you
project Veritas man uh this is a crazy
story from Veritas internet breaking top
level this is gonna this is gonna lead
to some stuff I'll just put it that way
yeah all right Athol Ironworks says free
the quartering Eliza blue is drifting
off of real victims sad and disgusting
yeah Jeremy is uh currently suspended
from Twitter as is Brittany venti and I
don't know too much about it other than
they they posted you guys know about
what happened they posted a photo of a
still from a video or something or the
video and then they got reported and
taken down yeah I don't know too much of
the details my understanding is they
posted the video of Eliza and from back
in the day when she'd made some kind of
it wasn't she wasn't nude or anything
but she was fairly scantily clad and
Jeremy so Jeremy was supposed to be on
the show I found out yesterday that he
was not coming on the show and what had
happened was he was confirmed for the
show initially but then it was like
something happened because I was talking
to him directly and he was like I'll
come out you know this Wednesday and
we're like yes and this was like a month
or two ago and then he was like Hey I
can't actually make it out let's
schedule and actually in advance so we
scheduled for the end of the month and
then Jeremy never got back to Cassandra
who does booking with any of the travel
information and she tried to reach out
to him I guess Jeremy said he flaked and
he apologizes and that he just didn't
get back in time we booked things pretty
far in advance so after a few emails
Cassandra didn't hear back she was like
Hey if we don't hear back anymore we
have to book somebody else and then we
ended up booking somebody else but uh
Jeremy is welcome to come here anytime
he wants I told him bro you got to come
out here we're supposed to talk coffee
man but uh open invite obviously we're
we're booked up
um we we book up decently foreign
Advanced like a month and a half or so
so it kind of sucks that we couldn't get
Jeremy out but uh anytime Jeremy wants
to come on we'll we'll try and figure
out how to make it work we do get
cancellation sometimes so Eliza blue
um hosted uh she presented an award at
the grifties I think 20 the first one of
them I mean she's on the list now she's
she's ranking up I mean people are
spamming the chat in the Super Chat
the chat is full of yeah Brittany venti
remarks about her body and and
uh Milkman yeah talking about the
quartering and pop culture got a super
chat about whatever's happening and all
of us look at each other like we don't
know what's going on we're not the
people to ask Chad is thirsty for
information about them there's uh they
don't want talking here's a good one uh
Christina H says Caitlin Bennett is back
on YouTube today after taking a year off
to enjoy being a new mom I wonder if
we'll ever see you right here on timcast
oh that's a gun girl that's gun girl
yeah yeah whatever happened to her she
took a year off to be a mom I guess oh
that's beautiful absolutely oh wow I
like guns should come as long as she
brings her baby yeah I want to see the
baby you know okay is that a baby got
guns
hopefully it's like you you get your
baby if I get to hold her baby she can
come you get a baby gun when you're old
enough they're like this is your baby
gun and you open it and then you get
that video of that's author that made
everything actually you know about the
22 Cricket right
hold on think about this think about is
this is a nice little tradition you get
a a model from the year that you the kid
was born it's their baby gun and then
when they're old enough
it's you know bequeathed to them oh and
then it's like because think about this
it'll be 20 years later 18 years later
or maybe 16 depending on the laws with
parental supervision and you've got a 16
year old it's an old school you know
older model and then you're like as
you're you're an adult it's your like
signature weapon yeah yeah I like that
yeah it's cool yeah maybe I'll do that
like we're not literally gonna hand the
baby a gun of course Media Matters will
write that we are but we're not what
will happen it'll be like locked in a
shelf and we'll be like when you're old
enough this is you know a 2024 model you
know 1911 whatever manufactured by
Springfield I've heard of parents like
buying like a bottle of wine that was
like produced the year they're like
their kid is born and then like they
gave him the baby why yeah
these beers are crazy no they'll save it
to like you know their 21st birthday oh
okay whatever yeah it's aged as old yeah
it's like and hopefully it's not
terrible
I like this one oh wait this is funny uh
Jason Dixon says Tim Google plays the
covid-19 information tab at the bottom
of your video I bet they were paid to do
this by big Pharma I don't really care
about that stuff people are like oh they
put a tag on your video I'm like that's
stupid but who cares shout out to Google
yeah here we go Cole D lock says hey Tim
you talk about mandating gun ownership
as a joke look up gun gun law passed in
1792 never repealed it mandates 18 to 45
year olds purchase military style guns
so they could be called upon for the
militia
so my bit was like we should mandate gun
ownership
but not in the sense that we literally
do we propose bills forcing Democrats to
negotiate down to people are allowed to
have guns oh you know what I mean so we
go to Congress and we say mandatory
mandatory gun ownership if you don't
have a gun you're in violation of the
law and they're gonna be like that's
crazy let's settle on anybody can buy a
gun but you don't have to have it fine
we'll repeal the NFA okay that's so far
D chest you're thinking right you wanna
know what's funny you all know it's
funny children have a right to keep in
bear arms
really yes and
you see the the issue that we're dealing
with is that culture supersedes the law
and because we as a culture have decided
children should not have guns maybe
because the power of guns the danger of
guns has has exponentially gone up we've
now decided they can't but hold on kids
back in the day when the second
amendment was written would be handed a
musket to do to hunt I went to I went to
um and there are certain laws where
they're like at 12 years old you're
allowed to wield a certain weapon as
long as your parents are around but I
went to I think it was a Stonewall
Jackson's house a house he used in the
kitchen this is amazing they have a they
have a Smooth Bore musket 1828 or
whatever you know why ready to go
because while they're cooking dinner
they'd open the back door somebody would
grab the musket and wait blast a critter
and then walk out grab the coat and
throw it in the stew no joke
and I was like what's the gun for and
they're like oh it's like open the door
and just shoot something and eat it it's
the dinner gun it's the dinner gun and
that they love it they would have young
kids using muskets granted a a a a
Smooth Bore muzzle loaded musket very
very different from a semi-automatic
Glock 17 or something so I understand
that yeah but but as we call that we
call that the supper semi but understand
this
just because technology changed doesn't
mean our rights did yeah okay so if
people have a problem with this and
disagree it has to be amended we as a
people have to codify that we recognize
the evolution of Technology changes
things but understand this too it is not
controversial to say the first amendment
applies to children that's a fact
so why wouldn't the second what changed
nothing in the law did
statutorily they just passed law saying
kids can't have guns anymore but how do
you supersede the constitution in that
way for that for that matter how did
they pass the NFA the National Firearms
Act literally does nothing but infringe
our right to keep in bear arms I mean
with the first moment like anyone from
the beginning of time the day they are
born in America they're guaranteed Free
Speech but we know that there's enough
legal precedence set where like if
you're in a public school Newsroom right
you're working your school paper like
the school is allowed to restrict your
freedom of speech it's allowed to
restrict your freedom of press there are
legal precedence set up over time that
school yes but
a child can walk outside and say what
they want to say their free speech is
protected sure but this becomes an issue
with social media right you'll have a
kid post something kid they'll get in
trouble at school are they and this is
like as you're saying like as technology
progresses we're continuing to battle
over the thing technically they have
free speech but we are in a state where
we want to restrict and limit the
greater point that Tim's making that
that is that we have
neglected to adjust laws to reflect the
way that Society desires the laws and
the reason the reason is because
changing those laws is hard right it's
hard to change so what I'm saying is
that they're doing it through the court
system yeah and it's like they don't
need to go to the legislature and repeal
law they just need to have a court case
that says this is legal precedent
yes and that and that is something that
we've that's called activist judges and
that's something that we should should
do our best to avoid you can't have a
judge be like well the Constitution
doesn't matter yes you don't want to let
you don't want to allow judges to
legislate From the Bench that's a
terrible idea it dilutes the the power
of the of the the legislature further
than it already is let's read this one
from Jeremiah dobler he says regarding
dudes admitting crimes to project
Veritas they don't believe what they're
doing is wrong yes I will counter that
not true the guy as I'm told physically
attacked the Veritas crew and I think
it's because he knows what he's doing is
wrong which is why he said don't we
don't want to tell the public this don't
tell anyone I told you he knows what
he's doing is wrong
but some some of these guys don't some
of them they say they're good guys yeah
some of them definitely yeah Raymond g
Stanley Jr says these narcissist freaks
always out themselves thinking that
they're bragging about how evil they are
hoping they'll score after the date I
guess you know they like women write
letters to serial killers man yeah maybe
as these guys are thinking like I'm not
at that level but I can be evil
[Laughter]
small say says James O'Keefe should walk
out like Chris Hansen at the end of the
date after they got the recording well
the reason that doesn't work is
they have to review the recording first
right like like we were talking about
what if some chick was in a date with a
Twitter employee ah I bet it's happened
and he's and they're like so what do you
do at Twitter I'm a moderator and what
do you do do you ban like I heard like
people banned conservatives I don't know
about all that but you know what me and
my friends are doing tomorrow we're
gonna go see Harry Potter we're gonna
start by watching the first movie all
the way to the eighth movie do you want
to come yeah no I'm interested in your
job oh well I don't really care about
that I'm a 11th level wizard in my Harry
Potter Club
I have a desert in my panties
but just just imagine the Veritas
b-sides I bet it's hilarious not only
that I bet James O'Keefe has actually
uncovered things that are probably not
in the public interest but kind of you
know like a guy saying something like oh
my job at Twitter is to shovel like you
know the crap off the floor in the
bathrooms because the employees there
are filthy and don't use the toilet and
it's like James is thinking like
I don't know if this is newsworthy it's
just kind of gross but then kind of like
we want to know these weird things that
happen at these companies we kind of
kind of newsworthy you know who who's uh
O'Keefe should hire who has a lot of
experience with filming people
Undercover
Stephen Crowder
I'm playing Steve it's just a joke man I
just had to get that one open man I'm
just playing man call me on your channel
man I just played
T-Rex betcha says project Veritas was
Savage when he got in the face of that
New York Times Reporter stopped
supporting woke pet stores like Chewie
and Amazon support Freedom loving T-Rex
Pet Shop I'm writing that down right now
and I will but uh my question is do they
have the kidney medicine
oh true yeah bocus is on a special uh
kidney medicine will he still need it
after the stem cells well we don't know
if the stem cells are going to work yeah
but if they did work would he still need
the other medication I got it again no
probably not holler at me I got a kidney
form now the problem is he's got a bad
heart so we he can't get I I asked him
about a kidney transplant and they said
his heart's no good oh damn yeah surgery
so here's what I actually have a visited
Pfizer no
but uh the the look he's a gutter cat
right he's a rescue yeah okay and so it
probably happened as his mom ate garbage
and then got knocked up by another cat
that ate garbage yeah and then just
dated a cat by eating oh this is from
birth he's had this problem so um we
didn't know this
but he was a rescue we got uh we got him
when he was relatively young I think
maybe six months to a uh eight months or
whatever and then
all of a sudden he's about four years
old now I think he starts slowing down
he's not jumping and playing anymore
okay he's getting skinnier and then one
day he just slumped over and we were
like something's wrong and he was anemic
his his red blood cell count was was
near death damn and uh we saw him
falling over and if we didn't he'd
probably be dead by now brought to the
doctor that said his kidneys are failing
they're too small they can't support
this adult cat they're underdeveloped he
probably wasn't getting proper diet when
he was a kitten he was eating garbage
and then his heart has a valve defect a
genetic defect and they said we're sorry
these things happen so we don't know if
the stem cell therapy is going to fix
the kidney problem because they're
underdeveloped as it is okay but we're
gonna try yeah and we we asked him about
a kidney transplant what they do is
there's a cat that they're going to
euthanize because there's too many cats
and they say okay if you adopt it we
take the kidney from one cat we give it
to the other cat you you have to take
care of them both and then to go on a
special kidney diet okay and it's like
kind of brutal for the cat that's going
to get killed like we're taking your
kidney or you die yeah you know it's
like well they're gonna kill it it's
like what do we do what they got down
loud so they'd be all right well
hopefully we'll see what happens bogus
has been very spry he's been getting
intravenous fluids are not intravenous
subcutaneous fluids okay and he's been
getting uh red blood cell medicine but
the red blood cell medicine is now
unavailable damn so it's bad news yeah
and it's gonna take a few times
available because the economy's
collapsing I don't know ask Joe Biden
you can't get anything it's crazy like
the reason our new headquarters have
been delayed by like a year is because
materials are insane it's only hard to
get we can't even get the internet it's
been over a year and Comcast is like the
materials to build the internet don't
exist have a nice day
no joke internet we're so where we are
at West Virginia we have to actually
have them come out and lay internet in
the ground oh damn we're legit
developing in a rural area we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna bring uh this is
technically like area 52. you know I
thought he was an Illuminati yeah we
have a big building we have a we have a
40 a 40-foot building and you can see it
yeah so all the people around are like
what the is going on here like there's
this massive building and so uh just a
big ass building in the middle of
nowhere Mill nowhere and here's a funny
thing we're going to be skateboarding in
it we got a studio for production and a
space for skateboarding and other
activities and fun Shenanigans movies
and music
so apparently what happens is one of the
guys working on the project is probably
having a drink at a bar and someone asks
what's that crazy building so actually
I'm working on it yeah it's some guy who
does like a podcast who wants to like
skate inside or something and they were
like skate and he's like yeah so then
this person goes to their friend and
says some guy's gonna be like skating
around in it and they were like skating
around it that's so weird and then they
go online and say why is a rich guy
building a private skating rink yeah and
now they're imagining all of us going in
circles with roller skates I thought it
was an ice skating rink for a while I
thought it was roller skates I don't
know which one I want I want hotep Jesus
to do to do the first couple skate with
me at the new place
hell no I don't do that I'm sorry
let's read some more let's read some
alcohol
Tien says directed EV might not work
like they want the virus will evolve
randomly and if an escape mutant emerges
in the lab there's a very slim chance it
will be the same Escape mutant in the
population this is why I don't believe
him when he's like oh the idea is to
mutate the virus so that we can make
vaccines it's like
well I get the idea that you can direct
the evolution of the virus through gain
a function research style things yeah
but in the wild
it's going to be random you're like we
haven't planned for that one yeah like
if there's no it's going to turn out
yeah there's 18 billion variant
possibilities you think the one you
chose is going to be it I don't think so
man of course man these guys are smart
man Pfizer knows what they're doing you
got to back off Tim this alt propaganda
you know this all Illuminati you're
against the alt Illuminati thing yo you
want in is this the big Pharma grift
it's the big Pharma Griffin I'm
auditioning Lupe called me you want you
want you want to be a member of the alt
Illuminati I'm thinking about it I'm
going to the highest bidder I know you
got money so you know we definitely
could work something out just don't give
me no daily wire contracts and daily
well I'm just joking big boss man I'm
just joking just jokes I'll take that
contract that you sent to Crowder out
you can send me that exact one right now
you got no shame man
that's your second warning
third time I'm pulling the Kanye and I'm
walking out of here he's really friendly
it's okay I'm sitting down I'm not
getting up it's just I'm phobic okay all
right let's read some more let's read
some more I'm sorry Tim but yes if
you're in it I'm down all right let's do
it bad B says Tim is right I live in a
Democrat City I saw military teams come
into the City Trump was getting ready to
do what Tim said
maybe maybe
all right Samuel latcher says or is it
lacquer guys please contact your reps to
not just shoot down the ATF ruling but
actually gain ground in fortifying our
god-given rights they do listen ask for
no less than abolishing the ATF and
repealing the NFA and GCA 100 agreed
uh yeah guys I recommend you do
send a letter out to your reps call them
up it does work the uh the non-profits
on the left do this thing where they go
out in the streets in a downtown area
and they say do you want to help save
the environment yes fill out this
postcard that's all you got to do
they have 100 people do it they get
everyone to do 10 postcards now one day
politician walks into his office and
there's a stack on his desk of all of
these postcards signed by people
demanding change and he goes holy crap
and that gets their attention and then
they say okay okay this is what people
want this is what people want from us
so that kind of stuff does work man it's
not like it's a guarantee you just got
to do something yeah
all right Jimmy races in one sentence
you say the media would be forced to
report on the White House Church getting
burned down and the next you point out
nobody knows about the last two years in
Atlanta yes because I said it's called
weight the uh antifa lunatics in a
forest in Atlanta is not the White House
if the White House was set Ablaze it
would be international news if a forest
has a handful of ants by shooting at
cops
local news just doesn't talk about it
but imagine what would happen if antifa
broke down the fencing and stormed the
White House
yeah that would be International
headlines yeah headlines everywhere yeah
that'd be epic footage you're right the
weight
it would be it would be the five To None
Insurrection there'd be committees the
doj without rating the homes of far
leftists sure sure I'll even finally get
some answers yeah Wes Eisman says Tim
have you heard about the Pelosi act that
was submitted today I think Hannah
Claire mentioned it yeah the not stock
trading thing yeah that's good that's
good it's specifically between spouses
and I think it was Holly who introduced
it uh who knows when it'll be passed if
ever but I'll definitely keep an eye on
it here's a good one
good oh okay here's a good one JMK says
why do you insist on dying on the Demar
Hamlin Hill what do you seriously have
to gain if you are right
are you implying that Demar Demar Hamlin
actually was the the the venue and that
it is an extreme position to be like I
don't trust the media I'm not I'm not
quite sure do you guys think that was
DeMar Hamlin nah man that's a body
though
it was crazy what do you have to gain by
saying that they they created a clone in
Wuhan or viewers at the grippy tomorrow
both would nominate Demar Hammond for a
grifty
I don't know what's going on with Demar
Hamlin I just know we ain't get a good
shot of them that day I'm looking and
I'm looking and I'm like he got a mask
on and a hoodie then we get the snowy
scene and I'm like we see everybody else
clear but him and I'm like yeah he
Griffin yeah if it's not him he's he's
got a good grip going and I can't hate
you know I'm not a hater I don't hate on
the grip so if he Griffin hey Demar man
I wouldn't show my face for the next
year I'd be showing up to like speaking
engagements with a mask on and whatnot
he's building suspense for himself he is
it's not this is great marketing right
it works I I stand by the announcer said
we talked to like his family or whatever
he needs oxygen and then whoever walked
around no oxygen in sight so I don't
really understand they missed a key
detail uh I'm happy to die on this hill
it's time for me I can't wait until
people say I got a body double
I don't need that part the other thing
is you were talking about facts and
evidence why not just take a picture of
him with his face out like I think the
media is just trolling that that we
talked about yeah they could be trolling
the media could be trolling with this we
gotta be careful why wouldn't it be kind
of explain that theory too yeah because
then it makes then they can then they
can pull out tomorrow like maybe a
couple weeks from now like ha see all
you people crazy conspiracy theorists
they're wrong they're crazy and stuff
like that you know so I think I kind of
think that they're it's the same time
we're wrong like I I think he's alive I
just don't think that was him right so
if they pull him out later Am I Wrong
did they get me well I think what the
what what the the Unk saying is you know
they're gonna try and you know put their
foot in this yeah right to make it seem
like you know
build the buzz build the hype not really
show him and make you say those
accusations make you say those things
like no he's deceased whatever whatever
so they can come back later and
discredit you and say aha look what the
temple Illuminati said you know what I
mean I don't know if I get to be in the
Illuminati I think it might just be Tim
I'll work my way in not Phil's there
[Laughter]
it's cool I'm just kidding well I mean
unless you know Phil or anybody else
wants to identify any way they want you
know then that could be for anybody I
think it's clear the way that I identify
all right we got this is clear after the
last two uh strikes you had is clear
your new pronouns are she her Brad
Vitale says if we're just another
Republic that's falling to corruption we
can help the World by exposing why this
keeps happening good conversation
here here man all right let's see we got
you got a lot of conspiracy theorists
follow you that's right too many too
many men oh my and then mediamed is
going to write that yeah confirms Tim
pool's audience is nothing but
conspiracy theories this is bad for my
PR I don't know if I'm coming back
will you send a body double next time
you're publicly inducted in the auth
Illuminati bro there's no getting out
now Emma no never said you could leave
you could join but I I can't get out no
now you're running for life you know
what I quit it's all yours now it's just
you I am the new leader hey this is
actually a trick people do on Facebook
it's really funny you used to be able to
add anybody you wanted to a group and so
people would do this trick where they
would create a group called like you
know I I like pineapple pizza yeah add
you to it make you the leader and then
quit yeah and then you would be and you
wouldn't notice and then one day someone
would notice you're like the leader of
this group but but people would put you
know worse things in there yeah
all right Robert Bradbury says Grifton
is forgetting your beliefs and changing
the political beliefs of the Wind Joe
Biden is number one
basically Joe Biden's just but nobody
nominated him I didn't see his name his
name's not a fan you gotta nominate
grifties.com go nominating I was Biden
not on the grifties well you know
there's an internal committee but we try
to be Democratic right so obviously
we're going to grift we're going to put
the hoteps up there but the rest is on
the audience you know we don't have we
don't have any say so and if they're
saying he's been grifting his whole
career it may not seem like this year he
needs to nominate right yeah there is
some discretion there like you can't
just nominate anybody it's like nah you
know he hasn't been relevant this year
right this year I think Joe Biden could
definitely has he has potential
potential yeah
all right let's see we got he's got Hall
of Fame potential Caesar Augusta says
Tim I came in late but I haven't heard
you say Civil War yet if it's going to
pop off I promise it happens in Arizona
well it may be but the one thing you can
do is smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the share with
your friends become a member over at
timcast.com we're going to start
recording that members only uncensored
show we'll have it up for you in about
an hour so don't miss it as a member
you're supporting all the work we do
here all of our writers journalists all
of the crazy personalities plus our
cultural Endeavors so please become a
member to watch that show and so much
more you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
everywhere at timcast does the hotep
crew you guys want to shout anything out
grifties tomorrow tomorrow grifties.com
youtube.com hotep Nation we are dropping
the grifties Tim Castro we got special
guest Alex Stein Chrissy Maya oh you
guys are gonna absolutely love this one
of course Canon Hotel uncle hotep and
then right after that hotel has been
told you uh tune in to 8 P.M on YouTube
youtube.com Jesus
what do you got alcohol depth plus Canon
Hotel come over here if you want to
shout anything out no um tune in hotels
been told you every Thursday
um eight o'clock and also I uh
alcohol tip Factor every Sunday eight
o'clock uh check us out right on on
YouTube Canon on YouTube youtube.com
lean down so you can see yourself if you
can see yourself in the camera
Mama made it
no you can catch Candace speaks every
Monday at nine o'clock P.M J and Cannon
Tuesday at nine o'clock also we got the
hotel's been told you after party that
comes on directly after hotel's been
told you that's the Canon Hotel YouTube
channel and Canon Hotel Rumble channel
right on I'm Hannah Claire brimo I'm a
writer for timcast.com thank you guys
for watching tonight you should follow
Tim cast news on Twitter you can see my
work you can see work from all of our
journalists Shane Cashman Chris Carr
everyone who's excellent uh you can
follow me personally on Instagram at
Hannah claire.beat and you can follow me
on Twitter at HC brimlow thank you guys
so much I am a Phil That Remains the
band is All That Remains uh All That
Remains on YouTube All That Remains HQ
on Twitter Phil that remains on Twitter
Philip remains official on Instagram
give me a follow and I am at search.com
this is a good one thanks for coming out
guys absolutely absolutely is absolute
pleasure being here we will see all of
you over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out cheers